[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's wednesday again yep i
can't believe how quickly this week
rolls around
yeah just week goes by fast it seems
like just yesterday we were doing the
show about the entity haunting yeah no
no
yeah but no that was a week ago
what
i was going to tell them i went down got
some supplies today
and uh had to get vodka for the show
i went over next door to publix and
bought some stuff and i noticed they had
zing zang
which is a bloody mary mix mixer and she
was talking about bloody mary the other
day
so i picked up a thing of [ __ ] zhang
zang if you guys have never had that so
we're drinking bloody mary
man
i think it's the best bloody mary mix
it's got a [ __ ] ton of celery seeds in
it so it's kind of bitter it's tangy and
bitter well yeah that's good that's why
it's called zing zang
okay so james snap says who is mata hari
okay bye
um allegedly yeah
she was actually um she was kind of like
an exotic dancer and a courtesan
uh but she sort of got legendary because
she was actually executed as a spy after
world war one
um but her story is like actually really
uh a lot more complicated than that as i
film as i figured out but she's actually
like a really interesting person yeah i
discovered but i mean
she's [ __ ] they've made so many
[ __ ] movies about her yeah like going
back to the early days of hollywood
there was one with greta garbo but i
think there was even a couple before
that yeah and there have even been like
recent ones so i think that really her
legend hasn't faded to any great degree
because
there was still just a couple years ago
there was like an opera based on her and
there was like a ballet based on her and
they she turned up in like video games
and she was in uh her character was in
that movie the king's man which just
came out last year
[ __ ] like that so she's a pretty well
known like historical figure in world
war one
a little bit of a tragic character i
think but you know we'll get into that a
little bit yeah because stuff say about
it but i think i'll wait for it i'll
wait i'll wait till we got more people
here and i'll wait till we start getting
into depth into depth
of you know of this case
there's a
me coming from a military background
i got a lot to say about mata hari and
the intelligence community and the
tactics that they use and combat
effectiveness of female troops and in
combat and everything and and
what they want to have happen what never
happens and what really happens we're
going to talk about that in a bit
uh i'll come back and double back on
this later
in terms of combat effectiveness the
most effective [ __ ] role a woman
could ever have in combat is to be a spy
that results in a lot more dead people a
lot more
a lot more dead enemies
a lot more achieved objectives and that
can bring you victory all right
better woman out front in an m3 unit
with rifles in her hands yeah it doesn't
bring anything to the table that men
don't already have this is what a woman
has in her advantage
you want to kill a lot of people with a
woman you want to be a we want that
woman to be a spy that that's very
effective very effective why dudes can't
keep it in their [ __ ] pants
and there's so many powerful dudes that
screw broads and just tell them anything
dudes talk too they talk too [ __ ]
much
they think that woman loves them you
know
that's how you get them all right
intelligence is
information warfare always boils down to
information
and women can get it that'll bring you
victory the thing about mata hari though
uh and this might be kind of like
jumping ahead a little bit but there
were a lot of um documents about her
that were declassified in 2017
and let's just say that the popular
perception of her as like this you know
espionage like this whole like femme
fatale kind of thing
mostly exaggerated um
and well the real thing is never what
you see in a television it's always
simple
yeah and i mean
i and i'm talking like exaggerated like
maybe she didn't even do
one percent of the [ __ ] that got
attributed to her well she was in a
place where there was a nexus of a bunch
of [ __ ] where it could have been her it
might have been and that's how they
looked at it they we'll see we'll we'll
talk more about it yeah it's actually
like i said it's kind of she wasn't a
spy she had a good cover and she was and
she was a real good one she either
wasn't or she either wasn't one or she
was one and real good at it one of the
two
from what i know the case i don't know
all the details jenny's probably dug up
a lot more she probably was
number one thing is spies are always
camouflaged they're always deniable
the way they operate use them called
tradecraft they can deny everything and
there's always an out if they're good
so you couldn't even bring a criminal
case up against them
if they want spies gone you can't get
them convicted there's no evidence so
they just assassinate them
it's called wet work let me just kill
them
that's not what happened to her yeah
because you can't get anything to stick
on them
no i mean that's not what happened yeah
i know but i'm just talking about that's
happened when you find dead people
yeah that you suspect are spies what
happened is they had to kill the person
because there wasn't any way to get
anything on them you know what i mean no
no legal way of getting anything on them
so they just kill them
yeah john smith said was going to say
it's largely a myth around her yeah and
to be honest i think that
um
scholars and historians and stuff like
that kind of like some of them kind of
knew that even going back to you know
a long time ago but when the [ __ ] was
declassified in 2017 a lot of [ __ ] came
out that uh yeah that a lot of the stuff
about her was absolutely not
true or oh you know a lot of stuff was
pinned on her just to kind of like she
essentially ended up being like a
scapegoat they thought it was true
though is yeah well i i don't even know
if that's true i don't even know if
that's the case they just wanted it to
be true
no they wanted her to be a scapegoat
yeah this is what i'm saying they still
that's what i meant they wanted to be
you know they knew it wasn't true they
just
we'll get more into it yeah yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying so i'm just
saying seeing a few brief programs on it
and uh
you know i've seen her mention a couple
times in world war one history
uh but i don't know the intricacies of
the case
yeah and like i said it ends up being
like kind of sad because i kind of feel
like prior to
and you know i'm i'm not saying that
some historians didn't think that she
was innocent like prior to 2017 but
because there always was that you know
kind of thing going around
but after 2017 i do kind of feel like
more more people are like oh yeah
probably she was so that's like really
shitty that happened to her but yeah so
we'll we'll get into it i mean like i
said she was actually like a really
fascinating
person and i think she kind of like
in a way that sort of like reflected on
the culture of the time i guess because
it wasn't just the spy [ __ ] she was also
like an exotic dancer
um and a courtesan so i kind of feel
like the
the way that
um
sort of like public perception of her
shifted
um was kind of an interesting thing
about
you know that said a lot about like the
culture at large like going into world
war one you know what i'm saying because
she was
really famous and you did you just kind
of like it's interesting like how the
more is changed you know what i mean so
you know so there's that i just like i
said i knew
all i really knew about her before we
were gonna do the show about her was
like oh yeah she was supposed to be a
spy and she was like an exotic and i'd
seen like pictures of her and stuff and
she looks like cool as hell um you know
what i mean like her outfits and [ __ ]
but that's all i knew about her but like
the more i read about her i was like
yeah this is actually like kind of sad
it's kind of like a sad story which i
wasn't really expecting but uh you know
i mean
um yeah okay oh thanks just put some
more ice in it stirred it yeah yeah
um first thing like before we get into
the topic too much
uh dermot one of our patrons and friend
of the show uh sent me an amazon gift
card earlier today
and he wanted me to buy the last duel
that the new ridley's got movie you know
what i mean because we were talking
about that yeah yeah yeah yeah so thank
you very much for that
and yeah because i did actually want to
see that because the trailer looked good
but then
it seemed like nobody really like nobody
went to see it and i was just kind of
like
and then later i kept seeing reviews of
like this movie was really good it's
like why didn't anybody go see it what
the [ __ ] i don't know but maybe there
was like other stuff that came out at
the same time pandemic was happening too
wouldn't it
i think that was a little bit after
because i remember seeing
i don't know i remember us going to the
movie a lot and i don't know i don't
really remember when it was but i
remember seeing the trailer goes that
looks pretty good but we never went to
go see it for some reason i don't
remember i think where the move was
happening wouldn't it
we'll see like i said i don't even
remember when that was so possibly yeah
i mean we were moving around september
or october
so i don't know if that's when it came
out but
i don't know we'll see but thank you
anyway jeremy because
we are definitely going to get because i
do want to see it it looks pretty
kick-ass uh oscar says who the [ __ ] is
this
i guess a lot of people don't know who
she is i kind of thought
i mean i'd always knew she was and i
felt like you know they've made like 40
bajillion movies about her um so i kind
of figured that everybody kind of at
least sort of knew who she was like
she's even been in like recent movies
and [ __ ] but i guess she's a spy or
supposedly or maybe allegedly that's
right
this this program will kind of link up
with uh
some of them like like some of the
programs we did on number stations
which is inspire related
i remember that show you remember we did
one on number stations no i said i
remember that you remembered it yeah
yeah
yeah you got to listen to you listen to
the words coming out of my mouth
[Laughter]
it sounded like you didn't really
no i said yeah i said i remember that
show okay that was like i think it was
like i don't remember yeah it was like
episode five or something okay yeah well
we did it wasn't i think it wasn't just
about number stations i think we did one
called erie espionage and i think we
talked about summertime man yeah
summerton man and maybe is doll woman
it's doll woman yeah and number stations
i think i think we did all three of
those on one show maybe yeah and then
there was is doll one was the woman that
seems like she got a smoke inhalation
out in the woods right yeah well it
wasn't out in the woods it was out in
the mountains like they found her like
sitting on a fire the mountains is the
woods right
no no there was no woods have trees on
them trees well what's to me
two different things yeah woods just
means outside outside that's not what
that word means that's most people walk
out in the woods
you have to use the same definition that
most people are familiar with because
otherwise no one will know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about no out in the field
mountains and woods are two different
things yeah okay jen sometimes mountains
have woods on them listen to it but not
not in this case okay what i'm
technically correct and that's the best
one actually
yeah actually well no i'm just telling
you and then remember that remember the
other uh chick that they found uh shot
in the hotel room and she had the nine
millimeter
and they never really could identify her
and i said it sounded like she sounded
like he's germany sounds like he's
german to me i kind of vaguely remember
that one i mean i remember is a woman
more than
more than anything because that's like a
really famous case because they actually
never even figured out who she was the
other one was some girl that was acting
kind of strange
i think she was i think she was she was
in europe somewhere i don't think it was
ger it might have been germany
and they said she had a stranded accent
she had the black short hair and she was
wearing the kind of little kind of
80s early 80s kind of
mod looking not really mod but yeah you
know kind of post
kind of clothes and
i can't remember how she killed herself
she might have shot herself
or poisoned herself was that the one
that looked like she did that
i don't i don't remember but she had i
remember that she had a browning high
power and they were uh the british were
might have been in england i think
because i think it was the british guys
that were saying like what was she doing
with such a powerful weapon you know
which is that's a real common weapon
here
and um she was some kind of a spy
although that's right we saw that on
yeah some show or something yeah all the
labels of her clothes were removed to
make everything [ __ ] difficult to
track where she's been and they didn't
know who she was
and uh nobody ever claimed her pretty
girl 20s uh you know they usually
recruit them out of prisons
it's usually how they do it in the
prisons i was thinking the east german
prison probably where they got her
got her out of there as a teen or to get
her out of an orphanage
sometimes where they go they turn them
into a sex operative
for some reason she killed herself
i thought probably just was sick of the
life
that'd be a great uh band name sex
operative
yeah i know it is that's what they
suspected about haria being
yeah but like i said we'll we'll get
into that because it is actually like a
lot more complex story than that yeah
but you know that's that's kind of just
what it is but yeah it's i can i know we
did a show about is doll woman but i
think that we did
i think it was on that eerie espionage
show so that was like a long time ago
they still haven't figured out who the
hell that woman is
she had to be a spy though because well
they found all her [ __ ] like in the room
and she had like eight or nine different
passports and she had like a bunch of
wigs and [ __ ] like that i'm like that is
super sad i think she was another east
german
the east german
they were called the stasi but
in general uh i don't remember what
their version of
cia
type stuff was i
they they everything was all acronyms
but they were they were running a whole
network of sex operatives all throughout
europe trying to get the goods
on
western diplomats and western
businessmen and trying to game them you
know
getting them on camera doing things and
getting them to talk and
you know they didn't have internet they
didn't have
hacking and they didn't have ability to
get into your email and see what you're
saying or going through your messages
and [ __ ] all that's old school [ __ ] but
though you can still do it they still do
it you know
but nowadays it's electronically done
that's the easiest way
you know yeah you can just do it from
your couch just do it yeah
these damn tvs have cameras in them
microphones all of them
and uh
every smart tv i've had you look and
there's a little camera there
and there's no option i've never seen an
option to turn it on
so i don't know what the [ __ ]
there somebody's turning it on somewhere
so you better put some tape on that [ __ ]
i put tape on it
i don't trust them
man it just sounded crazy but somebody
somebody wants to watch you scratching
your balls who knows who knows it's like
something out of 1984 you just say the
wrong thing you know what i mean and
then who knows and then they're saying
we're gonna get that [ __ ]
although
it's more likely what they do it is they
use it for advertising algorithms and
selling data look here's the customer
that's looking for they're trying to
make money off it but then
a lot of the intelligence agencies are
now private it's ex-generals and [ __ ]
that own them and uh they pretend to be
they're like a front company
and they can do [ __ ] that the government
can't do
so they'll go out there and collect
information that way and then they'll
sell that information to [ __ ]
government agents like agencies like fbi
and cia
now they can't use it in court so they
never tell you how they know about you
but they'll figure out other ways to get
better information on you later it's how
they target you because they can't use
it in court against you it's illegal but
they'll get it they'll use it they're
not stupid
they're not planned by the rules i mean
why would you
you know you just don't you cheat
they cheat
john smith says there's a great book
called tunnel 57 about tunneling under
the berlin wall and getting people to
the west that sounds good actually
because i don't know i mean i know a
little bit about that but not like a
great deal
but you know
uh so do we want to get started you
still want to like talk about some other
[ __ ] like too couldn't get started you
want to get started
because everybody showed up yeah they're
in there i mean yeah yeah and like i
said this is kind of like i don't know i
found this like a really interesting
story because i didn't know a great deal
about her
uh when i started out
i just heard of her and thought she'd
make an interesting show and then you
know as usual i kind of go down the
rabbit hole and i'm just like oh it's
all kind of like fascinating [ __ ] about
that
um
camp guy i would be a bad spy asset i
just hang around drunk and don't do much
in the way of work right yeah that's
kind of like yeah it's like this
man if the [ __ ] big brother wants to
watch me i'm like okay well see how long
you can stay awake because i'm super
boring but anyway
uh so yeah mata hari obviously is not
her real name that was her stage name
her real name was marguerita
zell
and she was born in 1876 in the
netherlands actually so she was dutch
now
so a lot of later on can we'll get into
this um a lot of people say oh she
looked so exotic so she must have had
like some kind of exotic like heritage
like she was malaysian or you know or
even jewish or javanese or something
like that but she's absolutely not um
her family was dutch she just turned out
looking quote unquote exotic i guess and
then she like played it up later on um
because she's just absolutely dutch both
of her parents are
so her dad actually uh was kind of well
off like he owned a hat shop and he made
all these investments in the oil
industry and actually kind of made a
killing so while um margarita was young
the family was actually quite wealthy
so up until she was 13 she went to like
private schools and all this other kind
of stuff so she kind of had like a
really nice like privileged upbringing
she also had three younger brothers she
was the oldest
however
her dad went bankrupt in 1889
and her parents ended up divorcing
and then her mom her biological mom died
in 1891. now her dad two years later
like remarried and basically
you know the family kind of like
scattered to the four winds after that
uh margaret did not stay with her family
she went and lived with a godfather like
in another city
now she initially was going into
training to be a kindergarten teacher in
leiden in the uh in the netherlands
but
accounts differ uh some accounts say
that while she was at the school i
believe she was 15 or 16 at the time
uh some sources i read said that she
quote unquote had an affair with the
headmaster
whereas some other sources said that the
headmaster was kind of like
uh just like fogging on her all the time
uh so i don't know which one of those
things is true
um i don't know if she actually did get
involved with him or he was just trying
to get involved with her and she wasn't
having it or i don't really know like i
said she was only a teenager and i'm
presuming he was much older
so
that whole kind of thing happened
and then her godfather like pulled her
out of school
and so after that she kind of like took
off to another relative's house which
was uh in the hague which was her
uncle's house
now when she was 18 years old she's kind
of like and you have to think this is
the time period where i mean women
didn't really like some women had jobs i
guess but not really like you could be a
nurse or a teacher or some [ __ ] like
that but you didn't really have a lot of
career options um basically your thing
was like well you need to find a dude
with some money and marry him
so when she was 18 years old um she saw
like a newspaper ad
and it had been placed by this guy who
was a dutch uh colonel army captain his
name was rudolph macleod i know he has a
scottish last name but he was actually
dutch but his family going way back
we're scottish
now he was actually living in indonesia
or what back then was called the dutch
east indies because they owned it at
that time so she answers he like
basically put because this was like
pretty you know free internet obviously
so they would put ads in the newspaper
being like hey looking for a wife like
i'm moving out here and i would like to
be married at the time and i think the
ad said something like he wants somebody
good looking obviously um and somebody
charming blah blah so he had all these
things and she's like oh sounds like me
so she answers the ad
and then they ended up getting married
in 1895.
now because he was also quite wealthy uh
she actually kind of like went into the
upper class at that point uh so you know
they they had money and everything was
fine
and she moves with her new husband to
like um on the east side of uh the
island of java which is a place called
malang
now they ended up having two kids uh
norman john and louise jean like two two
little kids little boy and a girl little
boy and a girl
turns out though that uh this dude that
she married was um kind of a chode uh
physically abusive and alcoholic
he hadn't gotten a promotion and somehow
that was her fault uh you know so it
wasn't a fun time he also uh openly kept
a concubine which
although that was kind of like accepted
practice i guess among that class
it's still kind of like
it's it's still kind of like not well
she was not all that classy and she was
tacky you were supposed to let your wife
that you were kind of like waving it in
her face yeah you weren't you know what
i'm saying that was tacky that is a
little bit tacky i mean like i said i
kind of feel like yeah it was pretty
common practice but at least they had
the decency to like keep it on the down
low yeah so it didn't like embarrass
their wives yeah you weren't trying to
drop you nuts on your wife but uh but
this guy was apparently not too
concerned about that uh he was [ __ ]
digging it into her yeah and also he was
kind of like beating her up so also not
good and he was a drunk he was trying to
just dominate yeah i made the [ __ ] i got
you [ __ ] that kind of stuff but yeah i
got you you know i can replace you you
know that's what he's doing yeah it's a
it's a total power move
uh so at that point
and i mean fair play to her because i
kind of feel like a lot of women at this
time period through really no fault of
their own because what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do like i said they didn't have a
lot of options back then um but she was
kind of like sick of him and she's like
[ __ ] this i'm out of here you know what
i mean whereas a lot of women i think
just probably would have stayed because
what are they gonna do otherwise they're
gonna have to like you know live on the
streets or whatever yeah at least
let's put it this way
this is when 18 what now 60 wouldn't
well this was like the late 1800s early
19th oh okay
yeah if they played by the book they
were just supposed to kind of take that
[ __ ] and live yeah you were just kind of
supposed to because what would you do
like if you left like divorce wasn't
really all that acceptable yeah and
you'd be kind of like a scarlet woman
you couldn't really make much money on
your own
i think it might depend if whether or
not you were in europe or in the united
states or if you were in france or where
what which country you were in exactly
you were supposed to be a certain way
but if you actually go back in history
you can go back into the history of the
united states in the 1700s
even uh sixteen hundreds to a certain
extent eighteen hundreds
most people weren't playing by any of
those rules anyway according to what was
being written it was just that was
theoretical
like women weren't supposed to have jobs
but if you actually look at photographs
and then hear them talking they all had
jobs a lot of them they were working in
factories [ __ ] real bad conditions or
working in laundries or
you know selling products that they were
making they making pies and selling them
they had jobs it's just they weren't
there was limitations to what not only
what a woman could do just what anybody
could do poor people were all in the
same [ __ ]
they were all innocent i mean poor
people have always had massive
limitations even nowadays you still have
like massive limitations more
limitations
but
there's [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of entrance to
instances of people
in the olden days
male and female of
every race possible just breaking all
the rules and succeeded there was lots
of that
some people just would just go [ __ ] that
i'm gonna do what i want and they would
win
you know it was it was
ambition and skill is hard to fight that
some people could just get what they
wanted i mean they had some [ __ ] rich
powerful women
in the 1800s 1700s
it's just that they might have been
madames but they were [ __ ] powerful
friends with all the politicians well
that's kind of like what we're talking
about here i mean she had a bunch of
properties it kind of ended up biting
her in the ass in the end roller alert
but
um i think i've mentioned this before
but i read this i wish i could remember
what the name of it was but i read this
book like not too long ago that was
talking about british courtesans
during this time period that um that
were very wealthy and very powerful and
they had these they presided of these
big salons with all these intellectuals
and politicians and stuff coming there
and it was really interesting because
they were kind of like well within the
strictures of the society these women
were actually kind of like freer yeah
than women that were doing what they
were supposed to do
yeah just throughout history this even
goes back to the roman republic and
eras
social power trumped even legal power
if a person was [ __ ] very charismatic
they got their way like for instance uh
one of the damn roman emperors his wife
was just known as
as basically a porn star a high level
sexual
prostitute and entertainer and he loved
her he married her and [ __ ] she was
sucking wildly popular everybody liked
her
because they said that she was
extremely shrewd and intelligent and
real charming everybody liked her
i remember the name of her some of you
might drop in the comments
uh i don't think i think they talked
about the
i think cytonius talked about her but
anyway
were always people that broke the rules
just based on what they could do what
they were like
and some people totally got away with it
yeah and then the thing about it is i
think that
maybe other people tried it and didn't
get away with it and maybe like they got
like you know tamped back down and like
you don't hear about them as much i kind
of feel like you just hear about the
ones that were like kind of out and
proud and were like yeah deal with it
you know what i mean and then they
actually succeeded yeah they usually
came from nothing because nobody really
cared what poor women did
the poor woman could do anything
they didn't care
you know she could be a prostitute or do
this and that really nobody nobody
really cared what she did so it was kind
of like a
freedom in a certain way as soon as she
got married or she was in the middle
class or the upper class oh no no
well yeah then a lot of you know
ironically a lot of your freedoms then
were taken exactly exactly but some of
the like powerful
women came from the underclass but they
made something out of themselves and it
was usually a madam that's how it
started
but that sounds kind of lowly no they
were hanging out with the governors and
they were hanging out with all the
politicians
yeah and and they were
they were buying property and they were
extremely rich
and um
if anybody threatened them
she'd just talk to one of her boyfriends
who might have been the governor or the
local sheriff or with some anything you
know and they'd have your ass scratched
out so no
they all went very powerful women back
then i mean on the flip side of that
though i mean
with uh with all that power kind of came
a lot of danger as well yeah because
you're associating with all of these
powerful figures if they decide they
don't like your ass and if you do
something they don't like anymore then
they can absolutely
[ __ ] your life yeah but that applied to
the men too they killed each other
that's true they were just they were
playing higher stakes games
i kind of feel like and this is kind of
true like throughout human history i
guess but i kind of feel like the most
freedom in the sense of like freedom of
movement freedom to kind of do what you
wanted without people like getting all
up in your grill and [ __ ] like that were
either like really poor people or really
really rich people yeah
i kind of feel like if you're sort of in
the middle of the year i mean like i
said i'm not saying that oh it's so
awesome being super poor because it's
absolutely not it really sucks but
you know in some ways
the
your poverty gives you like an anonymity
yeah to a certain extent so there's
extreme wealth and power right where you
can like kind of get away with whatever
because no one's really gonna care
nobody's all that much historians over
and over again have commented that
the criminal underworld
and then the leadership class of every
society
tends to have very similar tastes and
very similar type personalities and
their mannerisms are real similar and
they go
tip eve throughout history went to
[ __ ] places like nightclubs or
brothels and they hung out with each
other they made contacts
and that's why you always have
politicians in the underworld
as kind of like working partners in a
certain way
because they're friends they all hang
out the clubs together
and it was always like that
and they get involved in politics
political parties and stuff that goes
all the way back to the roman roman
republic
paid paid agitators paid rioters all
that that shit's ancient they were doing
that 2000 years ago
you could pay to have some guys who are
friends of yours
start a riot at your [ __ ]
political um um opponents
[ __ ] uh speeches [ __ ] like that they
did that [ __ ] all the time then they
blame that guy it's the oldest trick in
the book the roman history books are
filled with it
stabbing people you get up five guys if
i could get up on a guy in the crowd and
one dude stabs him and then that dude
that did the stabbing
drops the knife and those three guys
point at an innocent person
he stabbed get him get him get him and
then the crowd goes after that guy and
they vanish that was another trick that
they used to do
that's like the same way that you try to
like blame a fart on somebody yeah
they had that [ __ ] down to a science of
how to kill somebody in public and blame
an innocent person it's like if you fart
and then you look at it look at the
person beside you like dude
yeah that's an old trick everybody knows
that one uh zach says i love the fact
that my introduction to her mata hari
that by the way uh was being a character
in the 60s casino royale bomb spoof of
all things that's right she was uh yeah
that was good like i said they made a
million movies most of them are just
called matahari like i said probably the
most famous one is had greta garbo in it
but they've even had like recent series
and [ __ ] like that about her so and yeah
she was a character in the in uh casino
royale from the 1960s and i think too
wasn't yeah wasn't she supposed to be
was it actually mata hari or was it like
the daughter of mata hari most man and
daughter already i kind of feel like the
character i can't like james bond never
exists in a story [ __ ] pre-world war
ii everything's exactly now mata hari
was actually like i said a character in
the recent movie the king's man
um i do know that but
yeah i think that was maybe like the
daughter
she was supposed to be like the daughter
of
matari of mata hari and james bond yeah
like they had [ __ ] and she had a kid
you know what i mean i think that's how
that went it's been a long time since
i've seen that movie uh but yeah so what
were you talking about okay
so
she she's with this [ __ ] dude who
beats her up and drinks and you know
[ __ ] this other woman and it's like
haha what are you gonna do about it blah
blah so she just like [ __ ] took off
and moved in with another dude
which i thought was very funny um yeah
another dutch officer she apparently
like was real into
and i'm not sure if this is true but i
think she like would even say like in
public like how much she loved like
military officers like she just thought
they were like banging military officers
was like the [ __ ] best and uh she
would rather like sleep with them than
uh you know military guys than any other
kind of
than any other big politicians or big
wealthy bankers or anything like that
she was like super into it and she was
totally apparently not um even like shy
about saying it so you know
so so she lives with this other guy now
as i said she's in uh java
so she gets real into like studying
indonesian culture which is where kind
of a lot of her persona like her stage
stuff came from
and she joins this local dance company
which apparently is where she learned
like some of her moves and whatnot
now she's writing back to her family in
the netherlands in
late uh in 1897
and she tells them she comes she has
come up with a stage name and that stage
name is matahari now matahari is
essentially the malay word for sun it
literally means i of the day
so that's what her name was so that's
kind of what she's more popularly known
as even though her real name is
marguerite giselle like i said
now her
butthole ex-husband or not even
ex-husband they're still married at this
point we're a but old husband um because
like oh please come back i miss you blah
blah you did that kind of like deal um
and so she's like okay fine so she goes
back to him but then he started being a
chode again so she's like okay um
she hung out for a while
and sort of like
you know got back into like her
indonesian studies and [ __ ] like that
she apparently like could speak a bunch
of languages um i don't know when she
learned them all exactly because like i
said she did have a pretty privileged uh
upbringing like a really good education
and stuff but i think she spoke like
four or five languages fluently as far
as i'm aware
um now here's a weird thing that
happened
in 1899
both of their children became really
really sick
now
i watched a bunch of documentaries about
her and most of the documentaries
said that the kids became sick because
one of their servants poisoned them
however
uh i was looking at some more recent
[ __ ]
and the more recent [ __ ] says you know
while it's possible that the servants
could have poisoned them they're not
entirely sure why
they think what the more likely scenario
is
is that
uh either
matahari or her husband or both of them
had syphilis
and had passed it on to their children
and that the treatment for syphilis in
this time period was
mercury
and that possibly the children uh were
actually sick from like
mercury like from the treatment for
syphilis i'm not sure if that's true or
not because like i said a lot of sources
say that their servants poison them but
i don't know if there's any evidence to
suggest the servants poisoned them and i
don't know what the motive for that
would be
um
because well the thing about it was that
her husband rudolph
thought oh maybe one of his enemies of
which he apparently had many because
maybe he was a douche i don't know but
um maybe he poisoned our kids maybe like
the enemy so i don't know i don't know i
think it's probably more likely that it
was some kind of treatment that they
were undergoing for syphilis because i
think
i'm pretty sure that rudolph had
syphilis and i think and he either got
it well because he was like a poonhound
so i think he got it someplace and i
think he gave it to her like gave it to
matahari and she didn't know and then
like she had kids and passed on to the
kids so you know there's another thing
that like makes him like a fascinating
[ __ ]
jerkle
was like hey hey have some syphilis but
yeah
so then so the kids are sick they move
back to um
the well the thing about it like their
little boy died actually
from the poisoning their little girl
survived i'm not sure i don't think she
was like completely right afterward but
she did live
so they moved back to the netherlands
uh and then they officially
separated in uh 1902 and then the
divorce was final in 1906.
now
uh mata hari got oh she got the custody
of the daughter rudolph was supposed to
pay child support
but of course he didn't
now the weird thing about it though was
that when the daughter went to visit her
dad she decided she didn't want to go
back and live with her mom so she stayed
with the dad now mata hari was kind of
upset about this because like i said
he's kind of a drunk and you know he
beat her up and stuff but he's like well
she's she rationalized it by saying well
he never hurt the kids
so he was a good dad even though he
wasn't really the greatest husband so
and that's what the girl like the little
girl wanted apparently so she's like
okay well i guess that's how that's
gonna go
now the daughter sadly ended up dying
quite young she was only 21 and they
think that maybe that's because of like
i said the syphilis that they were that
she had contracted from her parents
so 1903 monaharri moves to paris now
france would end up being kind of like
her adopted country she apparently like
really loved it there
she first started out as a circus uh
horse rider and she was called lady
macleod because like i said that was her
husband's last name
now there were some uh family members of
that guy like uh you know the mcleods
that were like really not happy about
this because like she's in a circus and
you know how they thought about circus
people back then
uh she also would um make some extra
money by being like an artist model [ __ ]
like that
now 1904 though she had kind of like
started her career as an exotic dancer
which is sort of like where she got her
you know europe-wide fame
she was actually around at the same time
as like isadora duncan and you know kind
of like real iconic like uh you know
people that were in like the early
modern dance movement
and around this time period like right
at the turn of the century a lot of
dance was kind of looking to
you know asian influences egyptian kind
of stuff it was very very big at that
time
so mata hari like fit right in with that
kind of stuff because she was very much
trying to put across this sort of like
exotic like exotic far east kind of like
a vibe even though she was dutch
probably ridiculous to watch the dance
too probably ridiculous i don't know
like i said her outfits were badass i
mean they looked really [ __ ] cool i
don't know what her dancing looks i've
seen some of those old films of like
what they thought was real cool in the
20s
is pretty bad
but you know some there were some
shining lights there you know some of
the girls were pretty good at dancing
little uh what's her name with a little
[ __ ]
black bob that did all the german films
here and there what was her name um
related dietrich no
i've never seen her dance
i'll think of her sorry i spaced out
yeah i think i forgot what you were she
was she was a teenager when she first
started out
and
did some pretty cool racy movies that
got banned
in the us they could only show them in
germany where she was played a
a homeless girl who got a theta bara no
oh [ __ ]
if you saw pictures of her she would
look totally moderate should little
black bob
i'll i'll figure i'll remember in a
minute
oracle said i just imagined a crossover
story involving mata hari josephine
baker and gypsy rose lee
louise brooks louise brooks exactly
they're photographs they're nudes of
louise brooks real classy art deco stuff
looks like it was [ __ ] shot today
she'd be a beauty by today's standards
kind of looked like a
kind of look like um
natalie portman is in a way about like
that i guess
which in the for the 20s that have been
that would have been good
a lot of people were in bad health
basically
well i gotta say i mean pictures i've
seen of mata hari yeah uh in her outfits
and she but she was mostly nude in most
of her pictures she didn't like a lot of
nude stuff but she was actually a
beautiful beautiful woman yeah uh she
was and i loved her outfits i mean they
were [ __ ]
so so cool like all her head pieces and
stuff like i said she was very she was
just dutch but she did kind of look
exotic what at least by those sta like
those days standards so she was like
playing that up a lot um you know saying
you know she was from
issues from like the far east and all
this other kind of stuff and people you
know these people kind of like phil yeah
oracle knew who i was talking about
louise brooks yeah
uh so yeah yeah okay so basically so her
debut
dance thing like was in 1905 and it was
at this uh museum called the musee we
may
uh in in paris
now
pretty much like when she the first time
she performed she was one of those
people that was like an overnight
success like everybody was talking about
her like the next day
and you know the fact that she was i
don't even think she did nudity at first
but the fact that it was kind of so
provocative and it was kind of exotic
and it was kind of like new around that
time and i feel like that was you know
there were a lot of imitators later on
but
like i said i've never you know i've
never seen her dance i don't think
anybody like videotaped it or anything
like that back then
but according to a lot of contemporaries
that saw it it was like really really
sensual and like really you know
everybody was like super into it
now she ended up becoming the mistress
of the guy who founded the museum who
was uh this industrialist who was like a
millionaire named uh emile guimei
now as i said she kind of posed her
character was that she was a javanese
princess
and she's like
you know it was kind of like like i said
it's like the art of the circus the art
of the you know just the [ __ ] she
was making up a persona which a lot of
performers did back then so it's not
like it was just her um you know she's
like oh yeah i've studied like the
sacred art of indian dance since i was a
child and blah blah blah
um so as i said they she was
photographed a lot of times the weird
thing about it is that there was a lot
of nudes and you can like look up on you
can google it and there's a bunch of
nudes of her but she never wanted
anybody to see her boobs so it's like
she'd be naked but she always had like a
breastplate or like a bra kind of thing
like a gold kind of thing on because she
didn't like she thought she was
flat-chested and she was really
self-conscious about it so
so you should sort of be like she'll
have like a breastplate thing but she'll
be like naked the rest of the time
um i'm checking it out yeah you yeah
yeah she's pretty awesome looking i
think yeah she is flat though
she's got a good figure though
no she's fat she's flat
but the thing is though is when you're
like that
you might as well just [ __ ] rock them
you know what i mean
well no here's one she she's not she's
not
you know
small b cup probably that's not totally
that's not flat yeah i didn't think it
was yeah she's just kind of small
chester i mean you know i've seen some
girls over there they're different
they're different they're different uh
foot different angle photos
yeah just like everything else it's
going to depend on yeah depends on the
outfit
yeah yeah [ __ ] she's just average you
know what i mean um
average chest
um the rest of her not bad especially
for the 20s
when they they didn't work no this was
the early
1900s yeah they didn't yes
1905 and 19 yeah okay so
no physical fitness you know they didn't
work out or anything they didn't know
anything about it they didn't really
know about nutrition
so you were
lucky to look decent it was more like
just genetics it definitely wasn't diet
well like i said she was she was kind of
lucky because she had grown up quite
wealthy when she was a kid so she
probably like got some good nutrition
when she was or at least better than
most people i would imagine
so you know uh oracle says mind you a
lot of dancers are small breasted like
other athletes yeah that's true that's
true
yeah i didn't think i i mean
i didn't see anything like particularly
she just looked like average like i said
she didn't look like
super flat or she didn't look like i
don't know i don't think about things in
those terms i guess i was just kind of
like looking at the outfit more than
anything and like just the whole gestalt
of it but i don't know i thought she
looked cool but yeah so so there's a lot
of naked pictures of her obviously and
you know
so she was photographed a lot back then
naked
and
poke no her what are you doing trying to
tear the books out of the bookshelf
she's not getting anything she's good
she's gonna do yeah
um but the thing about it was that
because of that like her ex-husband was
like oh well obviously look at this
[ __ ] like she can't have her daughter
back you know what i mean so he used oh
my god
look what you did did that to yourself
is she all right yeah she's like i
didn't do that yes yes she started like
cats are like little kids and she's she
pulled those books out on herself and
then ran
and she stopped and [ __ ] like
scratched herself and looked at me she
goes i didn't do that yes you did
there's a big pile of paperbacks right
there and she just pulled them on they
all came like out at once she was like
[ __ ] she looks all embarrassed she's
like
i told you not to do it i didn't do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's like she's
trying to act you're [ __ ] funny
she [ __ ] herself over and then [ __ ]
looks embarrassed about it yeah she did
something last night
and uh
she looked embarrassed at after it
oh um she walked in between me and me
and me and this thing i was watching
something on youtube she knocked it over
she was looking at it she touched and
knocked it over she was like oh
my gosh
yeah she gets kind of shy if you like
yeah because i don't i don't shout at
her i try not to shout at her but um
sometimes he'll be like pookie what'd
you do or like something like sometimes
she'll scare me and like uh you know
because she has a thing where when i'm
sitting over at my desk and like i'm
working at my computer sometimes she'll
jump up on
the arm of the chair and then jump up on
the desk
and then like it scares the crap out of
me because i don't hear her she said
then sometimes i'm like pokey she sees
me doing stuff so she thinks she can do
it and when she [ __ ] it up she gets
embarrassed
oh [ __ ]
you know i don't have hands and i said
no you should have tried it
[Laughter]
she's like give me come here you saw you
do it
daddy yeah i saw you doing it i thought
i could do it no it didn't work like
that yeah
but she tries she's like don't have any
little fingers yeah she tries to do what
i do fourth her down says cats know if
you're laughing at them oh they yeah
yeah we were talking about absolutely we
were actually talking about that the
other day because she did something
dorky yeah right i can't remember what
it was but she did something dorky and
like
yeah we laughed and like tom was making
i was like don't make fun of her and she
was like making a face like
she didn't be right
i try not to because she she does
understand even if she doesn't
understand the words i do think she
understands some words the tones but she
understands like the tone of your voice
absolutely um you know what i mean they
they have like little emotions just like
yeah so yeah
um all right so where was i okay so all
these naked pictures of her floating
around so her ex husband is like well
see obviously she's
uh a filthy [ __ ] so she shouldn't be
able to have her kid so
he was able to like keep the daughter
so uh
basically yeah she was she would do like
a stripper act
as i said now she started out with like
a um kind of like a body stocking you
know what i mean but
that was kind of like she had that for a
while i guess until she was more
confident and then she didn't have it
anymore but as i said she would never as
far as i know i don't think anybody ever
saw like she was never like naked boobs
but she would like she didn't have
anything on like on the bottom half you
know what i'm saying so she did like a
kind of a strip stripper act but she did
have like a jeweled breastplate and the
whole headpiece and all that kind of
stuff
now
as i mentioned
yeah like she wasn't actually like a
[ __ ] hindu princess or anything like
that but it was pretty common for people
that were dancers or circus performers
or anything like that to come up with
something that was like more exotic or
exciting which that's yeah that's the
foot the people that went into
that handsome bald [ __ ] he was
the [ __ ] that made bald cool the
original terminator made a whole [ __ ]
career over out of dressing up as some
kind of ethnic group he's either thai or
he's some kind of a [ __ ] an indian or
he's some kind of dude for some tribal
background go look up yo brenner and all
the photos of him and all those roles
he was he was another dude like karloff
that just played some other race that's
kind of what he did
now
he was a he was a russian he had a lot
of russian descent in him and i think he
might have had a little bit of mongolian
in him one of the things that i heard he
did he did his eyes did slightly look a
little bit you know asian
but a lot of russians have those eyes
and it might be the mongols i don't know
but they can same deal same deal you
know what i mean they did they did [ __ ]
like that up until very recently
which i thought was cool sound of a good
actor
you know i'm gonna play a [ __ ] you
know tibetan [ __ ] warlord you know
you had john wayne doing that and [ __ ]
you know whatever
i'm sorry i don't buy john wayne as a
tibetan warlord yeah
i mean some actors i'll let it slide
yeah but john wayne not so much
i don't think that's good well you see
the thing is is that people paid to see
it i know that that's that's all that
well yeah i know that's what that's all
they care about really is all they care
about
um
oracle says edwardian and victorian
women exercise though there are
victorian arab manuals demonstrating
exercise for women yeah and i laugh at
i've seen him
that's not that wouldn't do anything
not enough resistance
well better than just sitting around
your ass probably
hot repetitions with no weight really
doesn't amount to anything other than
energy expended so you burn some
calories
but why don't you just walk
a run or right well i think they did
that to you yeah i mean they walked yes
so you know
there's a
there's the fitness industry has been a
couple centuries of [ __ ] um
jenny's gonna get mad she don't want me
doing this the fitness industry has been
[ __ ] two or three centuries going
back thousands of years really probably
because rome had it also uh of uh lies
lies and gimmicks
shake weight won't do anything for you
the [ __ ] booty master it won't do
anything for you not these things that
they sell people and tell people they
didn't do anything for anybody i can
eugen stand out dude who [ __ ]
invented bodybuilding even the system
that he [ __ ] sold to other people
really wouldn't do much
because it didn't involve any weight
all right
and if you read between the lines of
what he's telling them he says increase
the weight keep increasing the weight
but he only sold him five pound weights
he never sold him to five ten twenty
thirty forty fifty pound weights hundred
pound weights and so [ __ ] eugen santo
made [ __ ] 400 pound 300 pound lifts
that's how he got big
by lifting [ __ ] weight
and eating lots of meat he says that
yeah
well it's the same with women
you want that [ __ ] big booty shape
you see them girl those girls lift
weights or they inject something into
their ass but the best way to lift
weights do lots of squats heavy squats
and then do steroids they'll get [ __ ]
big ass on them i got pictures to prove
it okay look at rocky giovanni
it's a black girl who does roids and
[ __ ] does nothing but just try to get
a big ass he's got a huge muscular
[ __ ] ass
looks like something some
of this venus statue that them damn
crowmanians [ __ ]
were carried around in their pockets
instead that's what rocket giant body
looks like
but that's that's meat that's all muscle
you can't do that through little the
body responds to what you want if you
know how to do it
but a lot of the [ __ ] the victorians did
was a joke
they'd put they'd wrap something around
themselves and just vibrate it and think
that that was going to make it big
or small depending on whoever who sold
it to him it was gimmicks
zach said uh on this note i think a show
about isadora duncan would be cool it
would actually that now didn't is it
please forgive me if i'm wrong but
didn't isadora duncan die when her scarf
got caught in the wheel of a car and
that's his triangle that sounds like
yeah yeah yeah she was like one of the
best known like dancers of all time
grampher said uh ironic thing about
strippers as hot as they may be their
boyfriends are usually harsh looking
cockroaches
well it depends it depends
he's either in a local bed and he's hot
as [ __ ] because we know some of those
or he's just less overweight [ __ ]
just
cockroach looking dude or just yeah i've
noticed that and when you were talking
about yule brenner fourth showdown said
a tradition kept alive by steven seagal
bald and of indeterminate nationality
yeah
[Laughter]
bald-ish
yeah he just he paints his hair
on hey you don't know how much of its
paint brenner was yule was the [ __ ]
uh taken out early by cigarettes [ __ ]
died of lung cancer yeah he did that
commercial did yeah joel was
one of the first dudes one you know he
was up there with some of the other
early hollywood actors that actually
they had physiques
uh he wasn't i think he did a little bit
of stuff maybe a little bit of test or
something because there are some times
where he looks pretty good but he stayed
within kind of like natural boundaries
he didn't go supernatural like some
dudes did but uh
i've seen [ __ ] bret bretter there's a
lot of photos of him he did he would do
nude photo shoots brenner he wasn't he
wasn't shy he knew he looked pretty good
uh uh for his day he was a handsome man
and [ __ ] could act he could act
he did great
on stage live performances could sing
the king and i and stuff he was he was
just a good performer really good
and everybody loved him
he didn't know he didn't have any
enemies everybody said but brennan was
the was just a a good dude and fun to
party with evidently the women loved him
zack says you'll bring her was hot with
hair without he just doesn't do it for
me
[Laughter]
he didn't look famous i don't even
remember what he looked like with hair i
mean he just i was so used to seeing him
you know toward the end more to the end
of his career when he didn't you
remember
people remember him i think because he
was bald
it was a very unique look in his day
and um he looked good he just had this
kind of little feline look he was not a
big guy he was probably about my height
um
about five probably i put him at five
seven they always claim that those
[ __ ] are bigger
nah they always claim they're always
lying about their heights i think he's
probably about five zack says whoa i
just googled his nudes man it's hung
[Laughter]
see got the gays on him
i put them gays on him no brenner
brenner was the [ __ ] man he was really i
don't think i've ever seen nude photos
of him he was very cool i'll do i'll
show you
oh they were artistic you know what i
mean artistic nudes well yeah like i
said he's not gonna do like porn
necessarily that would like no brainer
was the [ __ ]
yeah mr 88 when we're talking about um
you know people like have like personas
or whatever he said they still do that
tom but they still do that tom cruise's
real last name is
mopath or mopather yeah john wayne's
real first name is marion yeah that's
right
oh okay
honestly i wouldn't even like recognize
him he doesn't look that i don't think
that's him there yeah i was gonna say
that looks a little that
[Laughter]
some of those aren't him i don't think
yeah
because i was going to say i don't like
recognize him with hair
yeah okay that's it that's him yeah okay
all right that's not him i don't think
no i think that's something no ashton
kushner that's somebody else
but uh that's not actually that's what i
said underneath it yeah some people are
like mislabeling [ __ ] well they're doing
that for the app for the google apps no
look brenner's got he's [ __ ] abbed
out and [ __ ] and everything right there
yeah
all right you guys are not kidding me um
you can't you can't really sit no i'll
cover that [ __ ] up yeah i was gonna say
don't get demonetized he was he was in
good shape
branner
all that [ __ ] bad
yeah
trying to get me demonetized yeah you
got money you know it's like and that
was when he was younger
he was started working out he got bigger
than that
you always got to check out the
[ __ ] that came before you look
how cool [ __ ] brenner looked
that's a cool picture actually yeah
starting 78 said i always confuse joel
brenner with lee van cleef
look at that [ __ ] photo of [ __ ]
brother
he's got hammer pants on yeah that he
was it was from the king and i yeah i
know it was yeah
it's called a joke
[Laughter]
look at him look at him as [ __ ]
pharaoh and [ __ ]
it's just uh no he was a [ __ ] cool
dude
and westworld yeah
the original terminator yeah he was the
original terminator
mr88 says i've only been to a strip club
once and the first girl i saw turned out
to be my girlfriend from junior high
and the club was in las vegas where
neither of us resided well there you go
there you go
oh okay granthar said steve mcqueen also
supposedly had like uh a big piece yeah
yeah i i heard it yeah he said google it
if you want to see a dirk digler-sized
daughter yeah
according to some people the
[ __ ] with the biggest
[ __ ] of all time was milton
berle
i've also heard roddy mcdowell you know
had a real big one well you could see
that he was he did some porny stuff in
[ __ ] caligula
hey right no that's malcolm
yeah
totally different dude it's not even
spelled the same yeah yeah
i got a hat it was a brain fork
[Laughter]
how did we get talking about big dicks
who knows before you get these gays
oh you're blaming the gays yeah i got to
be he's blaming the gays
you're going to blame them for
hurricanes too
[Laughter]
i mean some of you will get that i guess
but anyway
well steve mcqueen was the [ __ ] though
man
go go back and go just go so you're
saying that he could have just like
defeated the blob by like whacking it
with his just hit that [ __ ]
yeah this [ __ ] splash
[ __ ] with his uh mcqueen mcqueen is
really at his most mcqueeniest when and
[ __ ] as i said it's a mcqueeniest was
in in bullet
yeah once i saw bullet i was okay now i
understand i understand the [ __ ] the
mcqueen phenomena when i saw that
looking i even showed that to my boy and
[ __ ] he he's like
and he's in his 20s and he was like oh
yeah that was a badass [ __ ] flick
you know because it was just gritty
gritty gritty cops i kind of feel like
if you're a dude it's like you're
yeah you kind of have to like bullet i
kind of feel like it's one of those
movies that like all dudes like
you know what i mean
it's a dude flick yeah well although
it's mainly yes but i like it too yeah i
also like that movie
like one of the first modern kind of
like a
cop action type zack says i am to blame
yeah
yeah it's all fact it's understandable
well thank you for there for throwing
yourself under that bus just
understandable i totally understand
oh my god how do we get on these [ __ ]
topics yeah
it's your fault it's actually tom's
fault everything's thomas
[Laughter]
you and your sexual tyrannosaurus
but i got this [ __ ] on here this
increases my toxic masculinity that's
what it does oh that's okay yeah yeah
yeah okay so and then again
how big it is
yeah
because of this it's time i start
talking a certain way and then the gays
chime in and want to know how big your
brother's dick is that's [ __ ] we're
gonna find out we're gonna find out
we shall unveil it
for science
yeah it doesn't it's just scientific in
the spirit of scientific inquiry [ __ ]
right you know it's it's it's biology
it's a biology lesson acquiring minds
sure
uh hugo asked jenny have you seen the
movie mata hari from 1931 i have but it
was a very very very long time ago i was
actually planning to like re-watch it
for this and i didn't have me refresh
this drink for you all right i'm still
in my first one what the [ __ ] am i even
doing with mine they're good though they
are yeah it's just because they're
because it's zing zang because that's
tomatoes i love them but i was like i
can't drink it too fast because i'll
just get like horrible heartburn like i
have like some uh i have some pills like
that makes the heartburn a little bit
better but
you know what i mean so i'm just trying
to like take it slow so i'm not like
halfway through the show going oh god
i'm dying so you know what i mean
there's that and it sucks because i love
tomatoes and tomato sauce and anything
like that but
the older i get the worse it gets
getting old sucks you guys
uh zach said i saw a movie with harvey
keitel nude once
yeah i saw that was that the piano
yeah
playing a dude from new zealand meaning
someone had to attach a foreskin to old
harvey
that's right
was that the piano
cause i know i've seen him naked in some
movie or other and i'm pretty sure it
was the piano that gene campion movie
yeah that's the thing
if you if a dude has i mean you know
there's not like a lot of male nudity in
movies um in mainstream movies anyway so
i kind of feel like if a dude is playing
a character that's from a country where
they don't um
where they don't like cut their
foreskins off then like if the dude is
cut then they have to like put it on
they do that i don't know that's like so
that's something that never occurred to
me until zach just brought it up
[Laughter]
no i think he's leaving
because because they're like oh nobody
that'll that wouldn't occur to anybody
and zach it's like oh oh contraire it
does occur to somebody it occurred to
zach apparently because that absolutely
never would have occurred
i wouldn't even think about it it
wouldn't be deep into cockology it
wouldn't occur
the study of it yeah he wants to know
because the thing i'd just be like well
there's a dick you know what i mean it's
not really i'm not yeah i'm not like
worried about it
zach's gonna try to [ __ ] focus in on
the [ __ ] turtle head and [ __ ] [ __ ]
the the tortoise necks and all that kind
of stuff that's he's trying to do well
every time you talk about turtle head
that's always kind of that's that's kind
of like has a grosser connotation too
yeah it was the piano okay so yeah he
was naked and bad lieutenant too right
yeah started yesterday he was also naked
and bad lieutenant but it was the piano
that i was thinking of because i was
kind of like oh well that was more of
harvey kertel than i was expecting to
see in this movie but okay there there
we go i'm not mad about it i'm just
saying
uh yeah zack said i love that movie
actually i do too and i actually um i've
seen it a couple times but i wouldn't
mind seeing it again
now that uh now that you mention it
because i really uh think that movie is
like fantastic
uh billy uh bundy data said billy the
kid's large in jar at the smithsonian
say a billy the kid's dick in a jar of
smithsonian i don't believe that
i don't know i don't believe that how
can they prove that it's billy the kids
did they do dna on it or is it just some
random dudes he was just killed and
buried from when i if i remember on yeah
he got killed they just buried his well
maybe he just had like a big one and
people like i'm gonna save that [ __ ]
yeah
give me that pickle jar
[Laughter]
giving this to the smithsonian this is
some famous [ __ ] right here
holy crap all right
i don't know how this happens
yeah okay
like i said i know i'm going slow but
i'm trying not to i'm trying not to like
overwhelm myself
that's why one yeah
yeah
cause like i said i really like these
but
after a while i start getting like you
know
all right so
so she had like um a several year run
where she was super famous she was like
all over europe she was like kind of the
best known you know and like i said i've
never seen her dance i don't know what
her act was like but she did look super
cool and like all the pictures of her
and like from the contemporary reports
everyone talked about like how beguiling
she was and also
it seemed like she like her personality
too was like a big part of it because
everyone said she was like super
charming and um she just seemed like a
really like very like sexual sensual
like somebody you'd like really want to
hang out with she just seemed like had a
cool personality
now by 1910 she was so famous
that she had like a bunch of copycats
like there were a bunch of imitators
like uh traveling around europe as well
so i kind of feel like
because this is around that time right
where
the very very early 20th century
particularly in france where it was just
kind of like ooh like all
it was kind of like all the doors that
come off like oh all these naked dancing
and stuff it was very very
chic you know so she was kind of like
right in on the ground floor of that
uh
the thing about it though is obviously
by kind of more serious cultural
institutions or whatever they're like oh
she can't really dance and it's just
cheap exhibitionism and she's like
pretending to be some something she's
not a blah blah because they don't like
fun you know what i mean uh but
everybody else likes seemed to really
like her
so she went on for a quite a while like
that until about 1912.
now her career had kind of started going
downhill she was getting a little bit
older
um you know she had started dancing kind
of like later in life than dancers
usually start she wasn't old but you
know dancers usually start really young
and she was a little bit older and she
was also starting to like you know get a
little heavier
so there was that so her last show was
actually in 1915
but by the time she did her last show
she had actually become better known as
a very popular
courtesan
so
she pretty much had relationships with a
lot of like powerful men around this
time period as i said i think her
personality really helped her out in
this
uh realm because she did not seem to
have any problem at all um getting up
into the highest echelons and she was
like big high up military officers
politicians everything like big rich
dudes bankers [ __ ] like that um and she
would just like she'd be all about it
so
uh she so she was actually probably
better known for that like after her
dance career started kind of like going
downhill
um
than she had been for the dancing i feel
like
now the thing about it too was that
because she had these relationships with
all these powerful men
she was kind of like you know going back
and forth like all over europe right
now before world war one
this wasn't really a problem
um because she could just kind of like
and everybody like i said you know
particularly in france in the early 20th
century you know everything was like oh
very bohemian and there was all free
spirit and all these artists were there
and [ __ ] like that she was kind of like
in with that crowd but then like as it
became clear that world war one was
going to break out uh kind of the
cultural more started to shift
to a point where they're kind of like
seeing her again as like this a dirty
horror pretty much like she's like of
loose morals and she's promiscuous and
wanton and all this other kind of stuff
and maybe you know so it kind of like
shifted over that time period
now when world war one broke out uh the
netherlands where she was from uh
remained neutral
so because she held a dutch passport
she was able to
cut across national borders as she
wanted to
and she did that uh i don't really think
the thing about her is i think she was
actually like pretty intelligent or
pretty savvy in some ways
but i think that because she was kind of
like a kind of person that was like i do
what i want um i think it really didn't
occur to her like the seriousness or the
maybe like how suspicious it looked like
what she was doing because what she
would do she would go and visit like
lovers and stuff like that so she'd be
like hopping all over europe with her
dutch passport and when war was like
starting to ramp up and [ __ ] like that
that was starting to look a little more
suspicious and i don't think that really
occurred to her i think she was just
kind of like oh well hey i'm going to
visit this boyfriend or whatever and
she's just kind of like oh well there's
a battle over there so i gotta go over
here so she's like hopping around
borders and stuff and the fact that she
was doing that and the fact that she was
that she spoke a bunch of languages and
she was like kind of well known and
stuff like that you know it didn't
really uh make people like
it made people like kind of suspicious
like what she was up to
so uh
what ended up happening was during the
war uh she ends up getting into a
relationship with a much younger man
a guy named captain vadim masloff he was
23 years old
um that's a cool name it is actually a
cool russian name my but my [ __ ]
russian buddy who is from the russian
army back up in boston
when i was up in boston hanging out the
[ __ ] golf club i met a [ __ ]
uh an ex
russian soldier he was infantry also he
was goth and me and him became a buddy
his name was vadim vadim konyev
he's in germany now i [ __ ] got in
contact with him a couple months back i
thought
[ __ ] would and girls loved him
he had [ __ ] long black hair downwards
but look i look like a russian antonio
banderas out of the [ __ ] uh i showed
i showed him i showed him to jenny jenny
looks good man he's cute
yeah i don't remember that yeah what was
that
a couple years back he's good he's cute
yeah i remember that
yeah and um
yeah his name was vadim because it's
funny you said that
yeah only the d minor is roger vadim the
guy that directed barbarella yeah it was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] damnedest thing man
this is like [ __ ] 1990
uh
[Music]
1995 or
six
at the end of the [ __ ] cold war i
just watched the [ __ ] soviet union
collapsed
[ __ ] our army was helping them secure
their [ __ ] we were getting russian stuff
at fort campbell
behind helicopters and stuff we had a
real good relationship with the [ __ ]
russians
and just a few years later i'm in boston
in a goth club hanging out with a
[ __ ] ex-russian soldier and they're
[ __ ] doing goth [ __ ] it's like he's
got a computer [ __ ] doing guys shop
yeah dude gosh
he was trying to get me to come live
with him he had a big old [ __ ]
two-story house that was filled with
these [ __ ] strippers that and they
trained him they turned him into it
he's come work with me man quit your job
come work with me i would need you to
sell for me and then you sell these damn
computers good thing i didn't because he
went broke a couple years later
after i left he went i would have bought
me a couple more years in boston but he
went bro
but because computers got cheaper
he was selling used rebuilt computers
and those those kind of [ __ ] went out
of style you know they were expensive
back then
but uh that was funny man just a funny
episode i wish i had a picture of
[ __ ] vadim for back in those days
look like the lead singer look at a
small version of lead singer from typo
negative that's what he looked like
that's who i was picturing actually yeah
long black hair down to his waist
the type of negative yeah i don't
remember what that dude's name is but
yeah yeah it kind of looked like that
look like that and antonio banderas
[ __ ] those two dudes had a baby
that's what he looked like
okay
yeah
i mean i mean you probably did show me a
picture of him but i don't i don't
really show you a picture of him i don't
remember that at all oh yeah he's cute
yeah you showed me a lot of pictures and
i
probably don't remember like 99 we got
into so much trouble together
okay that's okay that's a side track go
ahead yeah plus what else is new yeah
yeah all right so uh so yeah so she's
going out with this uh captain video
maslov fella he was a russian pilot if
he was serving with the french army like
i said he was considerably younger than
her i don't think it was that crazy i
think maybe he was
well i don't know like how old would she
have been
i saw one thing that said oh she was 20
years older but that can't be right
because he was 23 at the time and she
died when she was 41. so obviously that
couldn't uh that couldn't happen so i
kind of feel like it was maybe i don't
know 15 years something like that but he
was a lot younger um she later ended up
calling him uh the love of her life now
he ended up getting sent to the western
front in
1916.
and a couple months after that he got
shot down uh during a dogfight with the
germans and he got like pretty badly
wounded he lost the sight in his left
eye
so at this point mata hari asks if she
has permission to go visit him like that
he was in a hospital near the front and
she wanted to go see him
now normally
she wouldn't be allowed that close to
the front because she's a citizen of a
neutral country the netherlands
uh so what happened was that she meets
up with agents from this kind of like
french whatever it's called the um dizzy
m bureau which i guess that's what is
that second something bureau i thought i
don't know i haven't taken french a long
time um
they said okay well we'll let you go see
your boyfriend
if you do some spy [ __ ] for us
and this is kind of where the whole
situation kind of started apparently
now
what ended up happening they said okay
now before the war started mata hari had
danced for
uh crown prince wilhelm who was the
oldest son of kaiser wilhelm ii
and crown prince wilhelm they had made
him sort of like a senior german general
on the western front
now
the the french bureau there they thought
well
you danced in front of he knows who you
are so why don't you go like seduce him
and get some information
out of him right
the thing about it though that it seems
that the the bureau didn't know
was that the crown prince
probably didn't know [ __ ]
they said the thing about it was that
they had put out a lot of like
propaganda about him being like this big
strong warrior and all this other kind
of stuff
because they didn't really want anybody
to know that he was just this kind of
like playboy he was just like going
around partying all the time and didn't
really give a [ __ ] about military stuff
so they kind of wanted to like project
this image to kind of like hide what he
was really like so they're saying they
gave him like this sort of like nominal
position
but
he probably didn't know anything of any
use but it seems like the french didn't
really know that
so they kind of sent her hey why don't
you go seduce him and get some
information out of him and then we'll
let you see your boyfriend
so
there's that i mean the dude was like i
don't know he was doing all this kind of
crazy [ __ ]
so
they said they would give mata hari a
million franks
if the if she could seduce him and like
get some good info about what the
germans were up to
uh but like i said
you know the crown prince
probably didn't know anything uh you
know because he was just like [ __ ]
around
and so
the thing about that okay so the guy
that was her contact like at the bureau
was a guy named george ledoux who
spoiler alert would actually end up
being one of her accusers later on so he
kind of like double-crossed her
essentially
so in late 1916
she's going uh she's taking a boat from
spain
and then she goes to uh fall mouth in uh
britain
and she got arrested there and she got
taken to london and she gets
interrogated by some dude from the new
scotland yard who was in charge of
counter espionage
now he said later on and he actually
wrote a book and he said all this kind
of stuff he said that she admitted
to working as a spy
for
uh the disease bureau
so they detained her at the police
station for a little while and then they
let her go to the savoy and like stay
there now there isn't a transcript of
the interview in the national archives
in britain and it does appear that she
admitted to it
but they're not really sure
why she did or
if she was just making stuff up
or
something because there was like some
sketchy [ __ ] about like why she would
have said what she said
now another thing that they did too it
seems to me that when they kind of first
got her involved in this [ __ ]
i mean she basically just wanted to see
her boyfriend and they were like well
you do this [ __ ] for us and then like
she didn't get any information out of
him because he didn't have any
information
and then it almost kind of seemed like
because she wasn't coming up with [ __ ]
then it's almost like the french sort of
like turned on her
and we're trying to make it seem like
they were trying to get her caught
essentially it seems like
so what ended up happening in december
of 1916
uh the second bureau of the french war
ministry
they they let her
get the names of six belgian agents
now five of them had been suspected of
submitting like fake uh papers and that
they were like working for the germans
and then the sixth one was suspected of
being a double agent working for both
germany and france at the same time
so they let her get those names
apparently
now two weeks
after mata hari had left paris she'd
gone to madrid
and then the double agent the sixth one
got executed by the germans
and the other five that had the fake
papers they kept on keeping on like
doing what they were doing
now this particular thing that happened
that made the second bureau think
oh well that must mean that mata hari
told this those six names to the germans
they didn't have any evidence of that
other than
that guy happened to get caught and
executed and the other five guys didn't
that was kind of like the only evidence
that they had that she had told anybody
anything they don't have any evidence
other than that that she did that
late 1916 uh so she goes to madrid and
then she ends up meeting with this uh
german dude like the military attache
whose name was arnold colley
and this is when she's kind of trying to
get in there to see the crown prince
right so she's like okay well can you
set up a meeting with the crown prince
because you know the french made me come
do this she didn't say that obviously
but that's kind of what she was thinking
now
during this time
and this is kind of what ended up like i
said biting her in the ass she
apparently
said that she would uh is that she would
share french secrets to germany in
exchange for money
but
what they think actually happened was
she was like just taking money from them
because she was mad that they had taken
away a bunch of her [ __ ] like her furs
and everything like that and she was
like okay well if you want to give me
some money fine but whatever
i don't really know like how that whole
kind of [ __ ] went down um you know i
don't know they were asking her to set
up a meeting with crown prince wilhelm
but i don't think that ever actually
happened
so january 1917
uh the military attached major collie
he sends radio messages to berlin
and they have a thing where he's talking
about oh we have this german spy who's
been really helpful and their code name
is h21
now the biography of this spy
is very very similar to mata hari's
background so they assume that that's
who they're talking about
however
the doozy m bureau intercepted these
messages and said oh age 21 that's mata
hari
however the messages were in code that
the german intelligence already knew
that the french had broken so it's
almost like they did it on purpose like
i said at this point it seems like
they're just trying to like frame her
so she i think she kind of like
blundered into this kind of [ __ ] and
maybe did some like questionable [ __ ]
and then all the dudes on either side
were like oh well we can use this to our
advantage and then they started like
manipulating her like doing [ __ ] behind
her back without her really being all
that aware of it yeah so they were doing
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean it's
like they were setting her up
it seems like
well second said before you said you
know she wanted to spy was she a spot oh
i didn't know all the details but just
in general if you get accused of it
you were in the mix of something
you know
so that's just what i'm saying maybe
they did get her involved but not all
the way but then they started to project
and then a bunch of fear happened from
different angles and
then she got cute you know okay go ahead
yeah i mean the thing about it i don't
know i wasn't there but it does seem to
me at least like from the new [ __ ] that
came out
that
she made a couple dumb decisions and
like took some money from people she
probably shouldn't have yeah but i don't
think i think she was more a victim of
like being naive than anything else yeah
but what the system's going to say yeah
well yeah for this and then you well
that's exactly that's exactly what yeah
that's exactly right that's so that's
how i looked at it from the very
beginning that's usually how it goes
here you know if you tell us this and
that of you know then i'll give you this
yeah okay boom you're a spy now
yeah well like i said i don't think she
really realized like the import of what
would come out of that right when people
think of spies they think of james bond
or they think you go to a spy school and
no
the cia's not spies okay no
they recruit spies
they get somebody that's in a position
that could know and they look if you get
this information from me i will pay you
this and they will work that person for
years that person is the spy
okay and that person is not trained in
any of that they're just giving them the
information
so that's
and that's what i thought she was
she was moving in the right circles i'm
yeah i'm just saying that i think that
people
you know when when you say oh that she
was a spy i think people kind of have
there's maybe a popular misconception
that is james bond well that she
actually like went into it knowing what
she was doing and she's like doing all
this like crazy like operative [ __ ] i
don't think that she just bumbled into
it and then i think she just got used
and she didn't really know what was
going on you sell it if you sell
information to a in to a country's
intelligence agencies agencies you're a
spy if you're selling information to
more than one agency you're a double
agent you're a double spot you're spying
for more than one
you don't have to come out
that that's how the law defines it
okay
you're not james bond you're just the
person selling information if you sell
that information to multiple states
you're [ __ ] you're a double
agent that's it and they'll kill you for
that
bundy data points out hedy lamarr
invented technology that led to wi-fi
yep that's absolutely true we should
probably actually do a show on hattie
lamar because she's also a fascinating
uh fascinating woman
but yeah so what ended up happening with
this so like i said it seemed like they
were kind of trying to set her up
so
you got the chief intelligence officer
of the german army uh walter nikolai
now at this point he's like look um
she's not giving us anything i thought
we were supposed to like get
intelligence from her like all she's
telling us is like oh this dude all he
was getting was like sex gossip he
wasn't like getting any military secrets
because like i said
i don't know like if she thought that's
but yeah but she's like yeah but this
dude's really hung or whatever i don't
know right i'm making that up but like i
said he wasn't getting anything like
anything
actionable it wasn't like any useful
information and it's called actionable
so he decided okay well what we're going
to do then we're getting kind of like
sick of this um we're going to expose
her to the french as a german spy so
that's what they were going to do that's
what they did
so i wonder why they did that i don't
know there's no need to do that no but
they did they could have just said okay
well you'll find out why later i mean
there was kind of a reason or there is a
reason that most historians like pretty
much agree yeah okay so february 1917
mata hari gets arrested uh in her hotel
in paris
and she got put on trial in july of that
year and accused of spying for germany
one of the main things that they accused
her of
was you know her the intelligence she
provided caused the death of 50 000
soldiers and that's something they used
to see like repeated um
they're like
she didn't give them any intelligence
though that's the thing they're like the
only intelligence she gave them was like
i said just like sex gossip about like
people she ended up sleeping with yeah
or like oh this dude's like a dirty
[ __ ] or whatever and like it's just
[ __ ] you could get out of the paper it
wasn't any like secret it was not
actionable she didn't yeah she didn't
give them anything right but they were
kind of claiming that they kind of
claimed that um because they wanted to
vilify her they wanted to basically say
hey you know she got all these people
killed i wonder why
uh i'll get to that um
yeah usually they don't do anything if
you're not a good agent they just stop
giving you money
they say we'll deal with you later
and then they put you on hold you never
hear them again according to the
information let's just say according to
what i've read that's what they said
you know i'm not you know well as i
mentioned earlier they kind of wanted to
make a scapegoat out of her for a
particular reason it must have been a
distraction from something else that
they were doing
let me go uh
well if you would wait
then you would find out instead of
trying to guess
he always tries to like sound smart like
but try to like guess like what's gonna
happen i'm like just wait and you'll
find out
um but yeah so significantly even though
they have this big trial oh my god she
caused like 50 000 deaths with all this
intelligence even though like i said it
didn't really seem like she gave them
anything that they could work with
um you know
they basically had zero solid evidence
zero solid evidence that she had done
that
uh one of her famous quotes that she
said uh on the stand i believe are you
know either at the trial or before the
trial was uh she said a harlot yes but a
traitorous never that's what she said so
she's like hey i'm a [ __ ] but
i'm not a spy so there's that now
interestingly the guy that was like the
main interrogator was this fella named
captain pierre bouchardon
and he was the one that would also like
uh
was the prosecutor at the trial as well
now one of the things that he found out
which as far as i know wasn't like a big
huge secret or anything
but one of the things that he like
leaned into really hard like at the
trial was that oh well your name isn't
really mata hari and you're not really
this exotic indonesian and she's like
well duh it's just kind of like it's
called like a staged persona like yeah
but the fact that he acted like it was
this big thing like oh that just shows
you're not trustworthy and you know
you're really dutch you're not from the
far east and exotic and all that other
prosecutorial [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying so they tried to make it like so
that just shows that she's like
dishonest you know what i mean
now
uh at the trial or during the
interrogation
mata hari did admit she's like yes i did
take 20 000 franks from a german
diplomat
who had been a lover of hers
um
she's like but she said i didn't really
think it was for anything in particular
she's like they had taken a bunch of my
belongings like my furs and my jewels
and stuff like that and i took the money
as reimbursement for that because they
had taken it away she's like that's at
least that's how she understood her
that's what she claimed at least
um but the prosecutor said no that was
like for you know first buying for
germany that was like a payment for that
even though she said she didn't really
know what they were talking about
um now the thing about it too ladoo who
was the guy that we mentioned earlier
uh he had also been
kind of like building a case against her
too and like everything she did was kind
of made to look like way worse than it
absolutely was and they think probably
and i think this maybe came to late like
in 2017 when they declassified the [ __ ]
was this guy actually like did some
evidence tampering as well so uh so
there was also that
now what happened in 1917 was that
france they had had some really big
embarrassing military failures okay
uh particularly like the novella
offensive there was like a couple other
things that were like really really
embarrassing for them and
they were kind of like afraid that the
whole country might collapse it's like
you know there was just this whole
[ __ ] thing
so a new government had come in come in
in uh july 1917
and this new government is like we are
absolutely going to win this war
now so it behooved them and this is what
most historians think probably happened
and why they made an example of mata
hari in particular
was like if we had one
spy like one german
spy that we could
kind of like scapegoat and then we could
blame a bunch of [ __ ] on like i said
that's why they were leaning so hard
into the she got 50 000 soldiers killed
uh thing even though there is absolutely
no evidence to support that
they're like if we can just they wanted
to kind of like have every like the
publix ire
directed on a particular target you know
what i'm saying
um so they decided that she was
basically gonna be the fall guy for that
to sort of distract from all of these
military failures that uh that the
french have been going through lately
so basically the thing about it was that
mata hari kind of ended up being
essentially like the perfect scapegoat
because
she um
was you know uh an exotic dancer she had
posed nude she was kind of like a woman
of loose morals or whatever you want to
call it she was divorced you know there
was a lot of stuff about her she had you
know she traveled all over europe she
had taken money apparently from the
germans and so they're gonna like make
that seem like she's just this terrible
person and she didn't the thing about it
was that she didn't really make a
particular secret about
being into like having sex with
lots of men or like powerful men she
wasn't like ashamed of it so i think
that really didn't help her either i
mean i don't think she was out there
like rubbing anyone's face in it but
like she was just kind of like yeah i
like having sex with like with dudes
okay like you know what i mean like it
wasn't i'm straight you know
it wasn't a big deal like it wasn't a
big deal and so
you know maybe that would have flown
earlier in this in the you know uh in
the 20th century when everyone was more
like freewheeling but once war had come
along and everyone was getting more like
[ __ ] angsty about [ __ ] then they're
like no that's absolutely not you know
she yeah so let me let me say something
to dj maniac hey maniac we're gonna see
[ __ ] gene loves jezebel [ __ ] next
week or the week after november we're
gonna get tickets to that i think it's
june 17th yeah i'm gonna see him i'm
gonna [ __ ] talk to him i'll get some
pictures with him
it's not both the twins it's just one of
them i'm jay i think it's jay i'm pretty
sure it's
true too bad they're playing at will's
pub playing at will's pub my favorite
place and uh my buddy uh my buddy
dimitri's uh spinning before the show so
yeah it's gonna be fun yeah gonna be fun
did you do the poster for that event
yeah but they said i mean i did but they
sent me most of the art yeah i mean i i
just kind of like
i just kind of like arranged it yeah
y'all never heard of gene loves jezebel
dj says they're playing here tomorrow
tom oh
another playlist i hope they play some
[ __ ] off of like the immigrant and the
discover album like the old the old
stuff
but you know we'll we'll see how it goes
because they had some [ __ ] in the 90s
that was like why are they doing this
and there's two gene loves jezebels for
you people okay for you people who don't
know we're talking about there was a
band called gene loves jezebel came out
in the 80s
and it was two twins from scotland or
whales were they from wales they're from
wales they were [ __ ] great man and it
was it was a great bad kind of liked the
cure a little bit in a way back in those
days
and uh over time they split and they
both owned the name gene loves jezebel
now there's two bands called gene loves
jezebel even though they don't get along
the twins
but uh and they both sang and i think
they both played guitar didn't they
i think they both played good i don't
remember no i don't remember i think one
of them played guitar and sang and the
other one just sang i feel like a lot of
times you like have a band with your
brother it never works out i mean look
at [ __ ] like jesus and mary chain or
like oasis so like all the bands like
when brothers they always end up liking
each other but
if you guys don't know the band i would
recommend to go and uh go on youtube and
look up gene loves jezebel
immigrant that's the name of that first
album and listen to that and then
discover i think that is the second or
the third one that that's a good album
too man [ __ ]
um they're just a really good band we're
going to see him we're going to see him
17th dj mini i said the boot blacks are
opening so be sure to catch them the
keyboard yeah we're going to see we're
going to we're going to be here i feel
like we might have seen the boot blacks
because i think they played at
absolution yeah last year or the year or
the last one i can't remember but i'm
pretty sure they played at one of them
yeah because i'm pretty sure we've seen
them before um but yeah yeah i think
they're opening at this show too
wait are they uh
there's like three bands yeah i can't
remember like i did like i said i did
three i did the poster but i can't we're
gonna get there early and uh
i'm gonna try to pre-game that's gonna
be an expensive show if i had to drink
that all night
i [ __ ] love to go to will's pub
i really like it here in orlando
it's a it's an orlando institution it's
an orlando it's the orlando's it's
orlando's version of cbgb's
it that's where you go see live clubs
yeah it's like a little i don't i don't
want to call it like a dive but because
it's kind of big but yeah and it's nice
now i don't like the new up i don't i
wish they still had the bar in the back
yeah they moved the bar to the front i'm
not a fan of that but you know that's
okay yeah in the back they put like a
pool table and like but it's kind of
like video games it's where all the cool
underground bands play
yeah and then they have they have a
place next door too that also has like
different kinds of music but you have
like [ __ ] over there too yeah yeah it's
a cool place i really like it like i
said it's been every time i go have a
good time it's been there i don't even
know yeah we usually i mean a starry
night all these places there like every
time they come that's where story plays
that's where uh well a lot of good bands
have played there since we've been there
yeah
uh okay so
all right where was i all right so
basically
basically i kind of feel like this poor
woman
uh you know maybe she made some dumbass
decisions but i kind of feel like
she sort of got caught in the middle of
stuff and didn't really know like the
the severity of like what she was
getting involved in
because the thing about it is that even
though they did ask her to like pass on
information or anything like but she
didn't pass on any information that was
like you said actionable she didn't like
pass on anything useful
so she didn't get anybody killed or
nothing like that as far as i know
uh you know but they just thought she'd
be like an easy
scapegoat she could be like an easy
person to point you and go look this is
like [ __ ]
she's a you know she's a foreigner they
were in france like she loved paris and
she lived there for a long time but she
wasn't from there she was dutch so that
was another thing that was against her
other than her being like you know naked
all the time and being an exotic dancer
and divorced and she also was a
foreigner so you know there was that too
so she's kind of like gets held up as
this
example of this is what happens when
when you a hoe kind of kind of thing
um now
basically she tried to get out of it
okay because she's on trial and she
knows this is going badly
so she basically she writes a bunch of
letters which i which still survive she
wrote to the dutch ambassador uh in
paris
and some of her letters are like um
she's like look um i only know all of
these people like all these important
people because i'm like a dancer like a
courtesan and stuff that's how i know
these people like i'm not a [ __ ] spy
um
and you know she's like i can't really
defend myself everything i say they're
making it like sound really bad
and the thing about it too oh this is
really shitty because remember how i
said that she was real into like that
russian dude um vadim masloff right and
she said that he was like the love of
her life
during the trial
um he had gotten kind of like pissed off
because like i said he lost you know he
lost the sight in his eye he might have
like lost the whole eyeball i'm not
entirely sure like he got um shot down
by a by a german plane
and so he was kind of like a little uh
you know aggro about that
he would not
uh on her behalf at the trial
he told her
that
i don't care if you get convicted or not
and man that [ __ ] her up can you
imagine like cause like i said she
apparently like really really loved this
dude yeah he was a lot younger but he
was supposedly like oh the love of her
life and everything like that and she's
like hey bro like why don't you like
speak up for me because you know shit's
not going too well and he's like don't
care
so you know
now what i heard i watched this other
documentary that um there's a little
more recent one and it said that he had
actually written a letter to her later
um that it's like oh i'm sorry i did
that i love you i love you and all this
other kind of stuff but she never got to
read it because you know she was uh
in prison and then like she got uh
she got executed uh so she never
actually got to read she never received
the letter so she died thinking that he
had just like [ __ ] her over and said i
don't give a [ __ ] what happens to you so
you know that's nice
um now
here's another thing
she had a defense uh counsel a defense
lawyer named uh edward clooney now he
was like a a
really well-regarded uh lawyer however
at the trial
they wouldn't let him
cross-examine any of the prosecution's
witnesses
and they wouldn't let him examine his
own witnesses either
and i'm like on what [ __ ] universe is
that okay
it's like so why was he even there then
like they wouldn't even like let him do
anything at the [ __ ] trial like her
defense attorney so there was that
that's not the american system
well it wasn't that system either that's
why everybody's commenting on it they're
like that's some [ __ ] right there
that's some [ __ ] yeah
um so yeah so her defense attorney
wasn't even really able to defend her
right like scarily
um and like the prosecutor just kept
like [ __ ] going at her this is a
quote from the trial he says without
scruples accustomed to making use of men
she is the type of woman who was born to
be a spy oh yeah that's what he said
yeah all that kind of those [ __ ] yes
i know those [ __ ] yeah and yeah so
they're trying to make her seem like and
and i to a large extent they succeeded
because a lot of movies and a lot of
times when you see her character like
portrayed in movies or other things like
that it's as like this exotic femme
fatale type of character and i feel like
she maybe wasn't like that because
you're saying she gave no actionable
intelligence that could have made any
impact on the battlefield that's the
problem you got to have in
information that impacts the battlefield
or at least
the internal political structure of the
enemy's
nation and she provided neither from
what you're saying earlier yeah so
even if she was a spy she wasn't a great
spy not one that gave over and like i
said they didn't really have any
evidence of her doing any actual spying
okay really yeah um
there were some like news reports that
came out after she got executed that say
oh she admitted spying for germany but
there's no evidence that she did that
either so they think that maybe that was
again i think she just kind of got
[ __ ] she kind of got [ __ ] shafted
man railroaded she got railroaded into
that [ __ ] it must have been a it must
have been well you said there's more to
it later but what i'm thinking based on
what you've said so far
it's a pro some kind of a propaganda
well that's exactly what it was it seems
like it was a propaganda thing i'm not
saying not spy
i'm not saying that you know she didn't
like
do some dumb ass [ __ ] like you know
somebody take him from take money like
take money for information but i'm just
saying that i don't think that she
really understood
that it was that big a deal or she'd and
like i said she didn't give them any
information that they
could have used that they could have
used or that they didn't already have so
it's not like she was in there like oh
i'm gonna sleep with this guy and get
all the secrets she wasn't doing that
yeah so that means that
they found out about that and one of
those nate and somebody in that nation
wanted to make an example out of her
yeah that's exactly what and it worked
to make sure no one would spy it worked
yeah
um so basically i mean she said through
the whole trial you know i've never been
a german spy she's like look i love
france i would never spy you know she
she lived there she moved there she you
know that was like her adopted homeland
and so she's like i would never like
betray it
um
and honestly like lately i kind of feel
like there's uh
later on like in 2001
there um there were some documents
released from mi5 you know like the
british uh intelligence thing and then
there was a dutch group who were kind of
like mata hari foundation like they're
kind of like backers of her so they
actually took these papers and were
released by mi5 back in the early 2000s
and
they tried to get her they tried to go
to france and like try to get her
exonerated like posthumously because
they're like look the mi5 [ __ ] that came
out because this even came out back in
2001 they're like that showed that she
didn't do what they said she did yeah um
so can we like have her
you know exonerated like after you know
i mean it's too late now but you know
what i mean at least her memory
yeah that that's that's what i mean
um
yeah and their quote was um
maybe she wasn't entirely innocent but
it seems clear she wasn't the master spy
whose information sent thousands of
soldiers to their deaths as had has been
claimed
yeah i feel like a lot of the stuff
that's said about her was
this is political yeah okay here's
here's the real
deal on the ground
you can spend narrative and [ __ ]
print money and make all these [ __ ]
claims all you want but really warfare
always ends up
especially in in the world war one terms
ended up
ends up being something tactical
you had the european superpowers at each
other's throats and they were [ __ ]
deadlocked
millions and millions of [ __ ] people
got killed
in world war one some historians have
said that world war one was actually the
death of europe that it never recovered
from the casualties of world war one
uh that it was gonna be a [ __ ] world
superpower
had world war one not happened
but it did happen they took a [ __ ]
serious losses
in casualties especially france
okay
world war ii came it was more about
[ __ ]
the soviet union and the united states
fighting over europe
than it was europe fighting for anything
else europe is almost kind of like i
don't want to piss off any european
listeners europe is more of a puppet
state
of either
russia or the united states
they're little bitty countries
they're not strong by big country
standards
and what was really calling the shots in
world war one and doing all the damage
was not spying was the machine gun the
belt-fed machine gun had [ __ ] caused
had caused [ __ ] trench warfare
and
they were locked up
uh the [ __ ] thing there was one i
think was the battle of the psalm
where the french lost a million men to
belfast machine guns in a
day
yeah i'm not sure if it's a million but
it was a lot and
and
i remember some historians saying that
actually
the french never recovered from that
that they lost so many young young men
that's a lot
a breeding [ __ ] age that that was the
end of the french empire
and it didn't have anything to do with
[ __ ] spies and women selling
information it was the belt-fed
water-cooled machine gun
browning 303
that did it had water jacket on it and
everything and you could just sit there
and just mow dudes down across the
[ __ ] no man's land and you could only
do that because there were no tanks
tanks and aircraft broke the deadlock
that happened between belfed machine
guns
which allowed the mobile combined arms
warfare that you saw in world war ii
and what you're seeing now actually
to a certain extent in ukraine
the uh
i think i think this matari case that
jenny's talking about is a frustration
over that deadlock between superpowers
with belt-fed water-cooled machine guns
they were losing so many men some but
something had to be blamed somebody had
to take the rap for that and they
definitely didn't want spies involved
even though a woman's information could
not break that deadlock
the only thing that could break the
deadlock between those nations
was tanks and they didn't exist yet not
not in the types of tanks that you
needed and you needed strategic
bombing but the weird thing about
europeans is the europeans were still in
that white wig playing chess white boy
type let's line up and shoot at each
other type of mentality they didn't
believe in [ __ ] attacking
where weapons are produced they weren't
at that level yet
they thought warfare was dudes shooting
at each other that's the no
no
warfare is not honorable it's not a duel
that's what they think it is at this
point warfare is destroying your enemy's
ability to produce armies you do that by
bombing
factories
and killing civilians that's another
thing
and we were doing it
by the [ __ ] out of them german civilians
because civilians work in the factories
you know what i mean and they're the
ones that are [ __ ] allowing this
government to happen the civilians are
to blame not the government not these
factors so eventually it gets down to
[ __ ] world war ii was about fighting
your way around an enemy army and taking
it out on the breeding population you
were you're talking about
attempted genocide that's what
in world war ii that's what it was about
was really more about genocide
if you look at the american demand
on japan it was on in germany also our
demand was unconditional surrender
what the [ __ ] does that mean
unconditional surrender
that means roll over play dead we do we
do what we want with you
man there's really there's no country i
can think of that will accept something
like that that's genocide
or attempted genocide
luckily that didn't happen
against the japanese
they unconditionally surrendered after
you hit him with two atomic bombs
luckily we had a good warlord his name
was [ __ ] douglas macarthur who had
grown up in the far east in china
and he went oh no let's stop all this
fighting we gotta respect the emperor
and let's help japan
come back together we're not gonna
[ __ ] but you know what i mean for you
you have to understand think about it
from the japanese point of view what
would unconscious unconditional
surrender be
after they did what they did to china
and the nanjing [ __ ]
the man the rape of nanjing you know
what would what does that mean does that
mean we give you all of our women is
that is that what unconditional
surrender means because that's kind of
what the japanese would have done to the
chinese
so let's take this back to the [ __ ]
matari thing
her information could have not broken
the stalemate between his machine guns
machine guns dominated the the
battlefield of world war one
but somebody
they would i think i think the reason
why they killed her they wanted to make
an example out of her two was the
frustration of the fact that basically
the european superpowers were impotent
in the face of belt fed machine guns
they sat there and just killed each
other and held each held each other in
check for years
and
they just had treated themselves down to
damn near nothing you know
and um
this is like
it was
when a society's go under that amount of
stress there's kind of like a mass
psychosis
and i think she got caught up in that
mass psychosis
yeah she totally did yeah because i mean
the thing about it
at that time in world war one like
france was not doing so great and they
just had like a bunch of really really
big like military failures they're
talking about the society that were very
yeah that was one of them but that was
like really really embarrassing for them
yes and they said we need somebody like
that just serves like even if we can't
like blame everything on this one woman
right but we need somebody's gotta pay
yeah we need somebody that's gonna draw
everyone's like anger
like you know it's because it's much
easier to direct anger at a person right
rather than like some big amorphous
right
you know uh confluence of events that
you can't control really right so it's
like it's much easier to just like blame
a person right so i kind of feel like
that's what they did they're like yeah
everybody look at her like she's she's
this horror she's like look she's like
this naked
divorcee and she's not even from here
and blah blah blah and like you know
what i mean right and what the real
problem was was belt fed liquid cooled
machine guns that could be put into
bunkers and they could shoot at each
other for [ __ ] months and months on
end
and there was no tanks to break that
deadlock that's what the real problem
was and whenever let's go over the top
we'll rush to the other side and take
the enemy's positions and they all just
got machine gunned
you can't win a war by stopping machine
gun bullets with the chests of young men
it won't work and and they realized that
after they lost millions of men
you know yeah oops are bad oops yeah
well what do we do now well let's blame
this girl she
let's blame this spy they did it
we didn't do it
yeah i mean yeah
she was somebody's got to take the heat
like i said i'm not like
you know maybe she did some [ __ ] but
it's just like she was just in the wrong
place at the wrong time and like i said
i think she was more a victim of naivete
than it is yeah and her information did
not [ __ ] get those dudes machine
gunned no no
like i said she didn't give them any
information that they couldn't have got
from the [ __ ] newspaper it's been
played out over and over and over again
nobody could have won in world war one
all right uh
not with strategy
because everyone was held in check with
machine gun bunkers
and you just couldn't get across that no
man's land
so it was just a stalemate
stalemate
with high casualty
you know but they didn't know they
didn't know the pa
they didn't know
that something as simple as a bell-fed
machine gun could really just rule the
world
and it could until the advent of the
[ __ ] tank
that's why tanks appeared and that broke
that deadlock
they didn't have the aircraft necessary
to bomb factories
they had aircraft but they just weren't
any good they couldn't carry enough
bombs to blow up a factory effectively
they could drop a bomb at a factory and
then the factory be up and running then
[ __ ] two days later
so you know because you just couldn't
carry that much in them
so
it was frustration so they went after
this girl john gore said it was kind of
like an old-fashioned witch burning yeah
and by extension i think a lot of the
witch trials the european ones and the
american ones yeah it's like let's blame
these helpless women right blame
somebody for this [ __ ] that are kind of
weird or something like for all of our
problems the ugly girls did it yeah yeah
man like the [ __ ] crops won't grow my
cows die yeah [ __ ] over there dude i
got syphilis or whatever the [ __ ] must
be her fault yeah she's weird yeah
that's how weird girls fall yeah well
luckily we're kind of beyond that
animal are we are
i don't know if we are i think people
get blamed right i mean we're a little
bit better than that i mean at least
people are aware of it largely but
i i still think well you can blame
anybody for anything we're humans yeah
and humans are always going to fall into
that kind of trap but the thing about it
is that you have to come to a place
where as a human you have to understand
that you have these failings everybody
has them i have them you have them
everybody has them so the thing about it
is that you have to be comfortable
with
ambiguity you have to be comfortable
with
very very rarely is a problem caused by
one
specific thing or a specific specific
person here's another it's usually like
a whole bunch of different factors it's
a lot more nuanced it's a lot more
complicated and you have to be
okay with that you can't just say like
oh all of my problems
uh you know are attributable to this one
oh my ex-wife she [ __ ] me over i you
know she made me lose my job she maybe
i'm gonna go shoot her it's just it's
kind of it's that kind of thinking
you're blaming one person for all of
these problems that are caused by
zillions of different things and here
here's the biggest
one the problem of you realizing that
you may be wrong
that what you're thinking may be very
wrong
and there's a lot of people that will
never admit that they're wrong
and
i'm looking at what's happening today
and there's a lot of people doing a lot
of damage because they think they're
right you may be wrong
okay
and that's one of the things that could
drives me nuts i [ __ ] go well i did
this and that and i'm always like well
am i right or am i wrong am i right am i
seeing what i'm seeing or do i just
think i see what i'm seeing and because
you know letting the days go yeah yeah
there is water
i'm sorry when you say am i right
[Laughter]
and that's that's that's that's uh but
you know it's been that way since the
beginning of time
but when it comes to warfare
psychological operations are [ __ ] way
up there twisting the mind of your
opponent
is uh one of the main things controlling
the flow of information
uh being able to gaslight lying deceit
that's all part of warfare
now so
i'm constantly uh
analyzing
but follow your gut
and
you can always go back you could always
go back to the roman [ __ ] empire
era of [ __ ] just when that whatever
you see
or whatever you're being told
ask yourself
who benefits
who benefits
that's usually
an indication of
where this information is coming from if
this is true then who benefits
if this happened who benefits
and
you'll be able to
you'll be able to under
uncover enemies and to find the truth
that way
nothing is by accident
one if it happens once
it may be random if it happens twice it
might be a coincidence if it happens
three times it's enemy action it's enemy
activity
yeah always
mr 88 points out humility is not a
common human trait the adults point
fingers worse than toddlers yeah that's
true especially if money's involved
because it might cost them their job
okay and a motherfucker's never gonna
admit some [ __ ] that might cost them
their job
i kind of feel like i'm like
pathologically humble so to me it seems
kind of like and you project it on
others i would know you because you're a
good person you i've said yeah coming to
the show but i mean the thing about it
is most people are not good people
i don't think most people are not good i
just think most people are indifferent
or they don't care
which sometimes like amounts to the same
thing people that accrue power are tend
to be bad well yeah i'm not going to
disagree with you on that right yeah i'm
not going to disagree with that i'm just
saying that most people just like random
ass
you know
i don't have energy to accrue power i
don't care
you know what i mean i can't understand
the [ __ ] pathology involved in i want
to be in charge i'm going to do this and
that so i am in charge i'm just not like
that i'm too lazy to be in charge i
don't give a [ __ ]
it's that that i want to be a hall
monitor whatever y'all do what you want
i want to be the hall monitor you know
what i mean it's like that like there's
something wrong with you if you want to
be the first well i mean yeah i don't
get that personality i don't get it
either i don't get that person
maybe those people like get [ __ ] done
but you know i get [ __ ] done but i don't
i don't i'm not like that i don't i
don't really i don't get off on telling
other people what to do yeah i'm like
look as long as you're not hurting
anybody you do what you want and let me
do what you want we're all gonna do what
we want it'll all be fine i'm just very
chill like that i'm very laid back like
you know people can just
do what they do like i said as long as
it's like a serial killer or you know
molesting kids or something like as long
as you're not hurting anybody do what
you want i don't give a [ __ ] it doesn't
have anything to do with me it doesn't
just got bad people man that's what i
mean but yeah and obviously but i think
most people
i most people i think
i don't think most people hurt people on
purpose
like a lot of times people will hurt
people just out of like
selfishness or because they're not
really thinking about it you know what i
mean because they're just kind of like
self-absorbed which like i said it could
amount to the same thing but i don't
think most people are like actively
malevolent now there are there i mean
there is a certain percentage obviously
i write true crime i know that
but i do kind of feel like
most people i think that most bad [ __ ]
that happens
is usually a result of somebody
either like acting up because you know
what i was saying earlier like blaming
somebody for some [ __ ] that obviously
they're not responsible for but i think
it's mostly just because
i don't know i think a lot of it's just
like bad circumstances or or selfishness
self-absorption like you kind of like
thinking i'm the center of the world and
you know you're just projecting [ __ ] on
other people but
i don't know it's just kind of i'm like
i said i'm very laid back i don't really
give a [ __ ] what other people do i don't
want to tell people what to do i don't
want to because i don't like being told
what to do but so why would i want to
tell other people that's why i don't
want to run [ __ ] i don't like running
[ __ ] i generally just like to
do my own stuff
and not have anybody interfere with it
and i don't want to have to like boss
anybody else yeah either because i don't
like that i don't like making somebody
feel like they're beneath me i don't
like that kind of feeling somebody and
they're talking about how good the
french were the french were good the
french were always good
um
the front the heyday the french were the
1600s the 15 1600s they were [ __ ]
really good during that time
um this
1700s they were still [ __ ] rolling
the revolution happened which i think
kind of improved them
uh i'm a fan of [ __ ] napoleon
uh he he had some idiot idiosyncrasies
around him but you know what i mean he
was trying to do the right thing and
make a kind of a a republic
which was a lot better than a uh
[ __ ]
monarchies you know monarchies were a
lot of problems with monarchies
and napoleon was trying to really bring
back kind of like the glory of realm of
the roman republic
um
he was demonized a lot
uh
but especially by the monarchs
and because america
kind of has an anglo influence to it to
its history the way it's told
napoleon has always kind of shown in a
[ __ ] negative light but that was
because
we're getting it second hand
through
british monarchies napoleon was good he
was good
uh they were good all the way up until
um
the 60s
and the french started to decline it's a
small country and they they like they
lost their empire
kind of like the british
it's just uh every the rest of the world
caught up with them technologically you
know they didn't have the technological
advantage
that they had
but good cultures the french and
and there's been a [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] warfare between the french and
the english forever
and uh part of it was because they speak
different languages and they were so
similar
in in in many ways
both [ __ ] up their own asses you know
um
and that's just the way [ __ ]
strong cultures are like that they're
rivals you know
but no
the united states owes a lot
to the british and the french we we have
ancestry and traditions that came from
both and being being a child of the
south there's a lot of french
influence in the south new orleans and
also spanish influence you know so yeah
i mean i'm from florida this is mostly
spanish mostly spanish here but spanish
french and english spanish and seminole
the seminole indian and stuff and that's
another thing is uh how badass
the indians of the south were the
seminole choctaw and [ __ ] you know that
there's a lot of a lot of the culture of
the south has a lot of strong native
american influence to it
um
patriotic people people of people up
north mischaracterize the indians a lot
the
native american indians of the south
they mischaracterized them a lot when i
was in the army there was
lots of indians in there man they were
[ __ ] bros
and native americans have a higher rate
of [ __ ] enlistment into the army than
any other ethnic groups
they're very patriotic
and it's because the indians were
warrior cultures and indian men
only had two roots to acceptance in
their family to be a hunter or a warrior
which meant and nowadays that means you
got to go into the army
look at a lot of good indians when i'm
saying and eskimos we go in that asp
alaskans alaskans which are kind of like
inuit anyway yeah inuit
a lot of them they're also warriors and
they got their own national guard units
up there and they joined the regular
army too
[ __ ] [ __ ] were bad asses
and they were drunk they wanted to fight
you had to [ __ ] hold them down
you all know what i'm talking about but
now they're all good dudes all good
dudes you know
which brings me back to [ __ ] predator
one that's right that's the way american
combat units look that's that is not
artificial that's not some artificial
hollywood
[ __ ] representation [ __ ] that's it
it's white guys
hispanic guys black guys and indians and
that's what it looks like because that's
where our cultures came from
and that's what it looked like back then
i don't know if it looks like that now
i'm i'm
feeling bad for the us army right now
but it'll make a comeback hopefully
hopefully
going back to what we're saying earlier
in england says i just want to be a
swamp monster that doesn't have any
bills yeah yeah i don't i would i don't
know if i'd be a swamp monster i think
i'd rather be like a yeti so i could
live like in a cold environment but i
would
i would like to be a yeti with no bills
but other than that i hear you and it's
like yeah i don't want anybody telling
me what to do i don't honestly i don't
know i'm kind of one of those people
that
the fewer people i have to interact with
like on a day-to-day basis
the happier i am you know what i mean
i'm just kind of like [ __ ] what do you
want now jesus christ you know what i
mean i'm getting like that and i'm
getting like crabbier as i get older so
i know that i'm going that way but i
don't really care enough to do anything
about it i'm just saying
uh yeah american military 100 says
thomas correct native americans are
extremely patriotic i've had lakota and
navajo
shipmates yeah and i kind of feel like
too
i don't know is it a thing too where
it's like that's like a really good path
for them to especially ones that um
especially ones that uh grew up on
reservations like for example like
that's probably like a good bathroom
like get out of that maybe because
there's i know there's a lot of like
poverty on uh native american
reservations so okay so talking about
going back to mata hari
i will say that even though she insisted
to the last that she was completely
innocent that she would never spy for uh
you know she would never do anything
against france because she loved france
and she didn't spy for the germans and
all this other kind of stuff
i will say that you know even though she
was obviously like really uh
distraught by the fact that she couldn't
get any help
and you know her letters kind of show
that a lot that she was actually like um
you know like pretty upset about it as
you would be uh yeah so she got
sentenced to death
and they're gonna execute her by firing
squad
so i will say that even though she
proclaimed her innocence until the end
she died like a g
so
she goes out like they do the firing
squad i think it was 12
soldiers that were gonna shoot her
now normally they would kind of like tie
you to the post and like give you the uh
you know the blindfold and all that
other kind of stuff
but she's like i don't want to be tied
to the post i'll just stand here and
they asked if she wanted a blindfold and
she said no
so she just like stood there and stared
at them she just like looked at him
now i heard a story that some of the
some of the executioners like tried not
to hit her like deliberately i guess
but i don't know if that's true or not
um and apparently
i mean she wore like her nicest [ __ ]
like the last you know
yeah she wore like all the nicest
clothes that she had like her hat and
everything like that and she goes out
there and just stands in front of the
pole i don't want to blindfold i want to
look at you [ __ ] she just wanted
to look him right in the [ __ ] eye and
she did
and uh story goes that right before they
shot her she blew them a kiss
which
come on how [ __ ] badass is that
that's pretty badass
so
yeah
uh
the shitty thing though is that you
missed that whole thing about yeah i
went to the restroom what happened
no i said like when she got uh executed
okay by a firing squad i said she died
like a g
dad like a g yeah okay like i said she
didn't they asked her if she wanted a
blindfold she said no you know so she
could look at him in the eyes right they
didn't tire the pole nothing they said
the last thing she did she dressed up
all nice like put a hat on and stuff
like that they said last thing she did
was blew him a kiss
damn
okay i was like that's bad aspect that's
badass
i hope i don't know that's true but i
hope she really did that because that's
badass much respect even though she
insisted that she didn't do that [ __ ]
because she knew it was going to happen
well she couldn't have
yeah yeah didn't have the strength she
blew him okay but she took the money and
they blamed her they blamed her but she
didn't get enough hornet said that too
went out like a t that's what i said um
and actually even somebody that watched
the execution later on said man that
woman knows how to die yeah that's what
he said
because i was like yeah that was like
pretty classy but uh yeah so then the
shitty thing like she just kind of like
crumpled to the ground obviously like
after they shot her and then somebody
came somebody came over and like put the
revolver to her head and shot her again
make sure she was dead yeah coup de
grace yeah
so make sure she wouldn't suffer yeah
so you know hopefully she'll be treated
with that
hopefully her body was treated with
respect well that's what we're gonna get
to okay
so uh since her body wasn't claimed by
any of her family because i guess they
believed all the [ __ ] that they they
were saying about her right so what they
did um you know when no one when the
family didn't claim the body and you'd
been executed as a you know as a
criminal
is they would give your body to science
to be uh you know for medical study
so uh her body went into medical study
now her head got embalmed yeah and they
kept it at the museum of anatomy in
paris
but in 2000 when they were going through
the archives uh they found that the head
was missing they're not entirely sure
where it has where it got to somebody
kept it but they think that uh well the
museum relocated back in the 1950s so
they're thinking maybe somebody like
moved it back then or it got moved or
somebody took it uh but they don't know
where her head is still so you know
there's that so her head's still missing
um so basically like i said because of
all of the sort of propaganda that they
put oh bless you sweetie
pokey sneeze um all the stuff that they
put out about her like after her
execution
um
her name kind of got associated with
this exotic like i said femme fatale
character she's like this
you know she's this like operative and
she has she has all these fabulous
outfits and she comes in and like you
know screws the guy and gets all this
information and like all this other kind
of stuff which is a little unfair
because that's not really like what the
real story was
but apparently um the character the
persona was so appealing that they've
made
a zillion [ __ ] well maybe not a
zillion but a lot they made like a lot
of movies like starting back in 1920 uh
they made one 1920 they made a 1927 one
1931 which is the one with greta garbo
which is one that most people are
familiar with they've been one of the
60s zach mentioned earlier that the
james bond baby casino royale had a
character that
was
called
mata bond who was basically like the
daughter of mata hari and james bond so
there was that
um there was a 1972 british movie with
jaja gabor
uh where
joshua bark played her
they made a television series in the 80s
there was an episode of fantasy island
about her there was an 85 movie there
was a 2016 movie uh there was a 2017
movie
there was a 2017 series that was uh
russian portuguese um and i mentioned
earlier that the movie the king's man
she's a character in that as well
so
she's also been the subject of five
count em five
stage musicals
a ballet which came out in 2016 or 2017
and an opera which came out in 2017 i
think so
clearly her legend oh and she's also the
subject of a pinball machine of all
things which came out in the late 1970s
isn't that funny um but yeah so there's
that so obviously
her legend i guess like struck a chord
um even though
the real story is not exactly like how
it's portrayed i guess but
you know that's kind of what happens
with see the thing about it is legends
are always like way more exciting than
reality i guess yeah in a lot of cases
sadly
so
what are you gonna do what are you going
to do
i mean i feel like really bad for her
yeah
yeah she got caught in the crossfire she
did and i mean in the worst possible way
like i said it's cool like she went out
like a g but
man
american
military 100 said tom is correct native
americans are extremely patriotic i've
had lakota and navajo [ __ ] my mates yeah
yeah my experience uh
like you can go check the statistics
out of any a meth out of any american
um ethnic group
uh rates of joining the service are the
highest among uh native americans
and [ __ ] no real patriotic real
badasses
um they're young you know when they come
in
and do a good job they [ __ ] love it
real popular in service everybody loves
them you know got good reputation
pacific islanders also
same type of deal like samoans and
hawaiians islanders micronesians
um
which we had a lot of micronesians in
our units the same way
here's the thing
people that are closer to nature this is
this includes southerners too like
people from mississippi or alabama
people who are kind of have a tribal
nature to them make much better soldiers
and they're a lot more patriotic kind of
nationalistic they're more about the
team team sport
type people
uh these aren't an urban people with
push button and
[ __ ]
computers hey i do that don't make it i
don't know i'm just saying they're just
not that people they're not that people
these are people about legends and
traditions and warrior traditions
and religions and they're into that
kind of thing
and it's more of a [ __ ]
masculine spirituality
so they're going to join the service
but in my experience islanders and
and native americans
top-notch when it comes to soldiering
and being policemen they like the fight
they don't run from the fight they like
the fight because they're proving their
manhood
they're reaffirming
and there's also the idea of ancest
ancestry and tradition
um you know so we've been talking about
them native american their traditions to
fight no no no no go back to the 1800s
a
biggest part of the u.s army cavalry of
the 1800s was the lakota
the the lakota was the us army cavalry
looking um
they're just photographs over and over
again in these damn army yearbooks
of [ __ ]
the dudes that were doing the patrols
out in the [ __ ]
out on the great plains because you see
the great plains warriors got absorbed
into the us army and [ __ ] they said
well to do what we have to do we have to
now join the us army and now
we'll have horses and uniforms and the
new flags and we'll represent our
[ __ ] land under the banner of america
and they were out there doing patrols
and [ __ ]
in u.s army uniforms
and you'll see it's all lakota
they might have had
white officers from up north to make
sure they weren't misbehaving
but this is the lakota
okay to put it in modern terms if you
watch a movie 300 you got a [ __ ]
osiris
or no what's his name
what's not cyrus
cyrus was the person yeah yeah the
persian guy yeah yeah yeah the persian
guy he's going you know he's given
trying to give the [ __ ]
trying to give the deal a new deal to
the pr to the spartans if you join me i
will you under my banner you will rule
europa and where you come from that's
that was kind of the deal the u.s army
in the u.s gave to the lakota and a lot
of the indians during the 1800s period
join us and and and you will rule your
homeland under our banner and that's
exactly what they did
but cops and
cops and soldiers man now the indians in
their area they [ __ ] kicked ass
kicked ass i served with them good dudes
and if you [ __ ] look at
indian scout indian scout mercenaries
and all that [ __ ] that goes back [ __ ]
centuries and [ __ ]
and you can in modern cultural
terminology you watch [ __ ] predator
one [ __ ] billy
they're their [ __ ] scout through the
mercenary group you know some people
think that predator one was about u.s
special forces no they were they were
contractors
there were contractors that came in to
save special forces guys
you know
that's why they were so jacked
okay that's all i'm gonna say about that
somebody needs to get those uh oh okay
message were deleted they're like spam
like oh spam yeah
get rid of the spam people yeah somebody
did okay rebecca says oh wow never seen
a bot in here before oh it happens it
happens it happens from time to time
yeah but usually we have people yeah sex
bots yeah it's usually sack spots six
bucks um actually somebody mentioned the
navajo code talkers that would probably
be a really good show good show yeah
actually hand me a pen okay uh and i'll
write that down and somebody said do a
show on jackie o as well which actually
would probably also be a good show
just whatever now the code talkers were
all sort of [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying i don't think
we've done a show about that that would
actually be quite
the code talker story
is actually the story of can't spell
really when you looked at the code
soccer story was the end of
the [ __ ] um
in many ways the end of the uh uh
reservations
indian reservations that was kind of the
end of them was a code talker story
because indian guys went off to [ __ ]
world war ii and when they came back
from world war ii they didn't go back to
the reservation they moved out to la and
they moved out to [ __ ] mississippi
and other places and they married white
women
so it was it was part of the integration
because they had seen the bigger world
they're not gonna go back to the [ __ ]
reservation
yeah
some did but most didn't you know yeah i
just honestly um i just actually read a
horror novel yeah uh that's i did a
review of it it's gonna go up on monday
yeah uh called the only good indians and
it was written by stephen graham jones
who was black feet
and it's actually kind of about like uh
for like blackfeet dudes and two of them
like stayed on the reservation and two
of them left and it's kind of like this
whole yeah why would you stay there's an
outside world you know what i mean
that's the same but you see here's the
thing the same thing happened to us in
mississippi
what what destroyed old school southern
culture was not warfare or anything like
that it was cable television we we saw
mtv
we saw prince
okay and we saw [ __ ] new wave music
and duran duran
and you're like oh [ __ ] i want to stay
here
this is good but i want to go out to the
[ __ ] club and that's you know that
was the end of the south
yeah i mean same thing happened i mean i
was never rolled super into like
rednecky [ __ ] either like you know i you
know i'm from florida but my family are
from tennessee yeah uh at least my dad's
side of the family are so you know very
southern and i'm just kind of like it
wasn't really ever my bag man but it's
just kind of like until i saw
new wave kind of [ __ ] or like gothi kind
of [ __ ] or like the addams family and
she's like oh okay
yeah
yeah i want to do that i don't want to
do this redneck right well the indians
were the same the indians were the same
way
okay
even back in the 40s in world war ii
they saw the [ __ ] bigger world and
they're like oh yeah yeah okay yeah the
reservation that that that that's okay
but man i can go to la
you know it's [ __ ] 1951. there's all
kinds of [ __ ] going on there [ __ ] and
you know the next thing you know they
just they just blended in with americans
you know they married white women
i mean the thing about it is that
i mean really as long as you i mean if
people want to stay like in mississippi
or people want to stay on the
reservation or whatever that's kind of
up to them everybody has their own
preference about how they want their
life to go yeah but
i don't know i kind of feel like if you
know but if you don't want to do that
and you want to go somewhere else and
like live in a big city or do something
else like that then i don't think you
should be like [ __ ] vilified for it
that's for sure yeah
the new generations in mississippi
are uh actually uh
indian like from india
and uh
uh chinese or yeah chinese
that
that's just where they go because it's
cut and vietnamese because it's the
temperatures that the weather is kind of
like the mekong delta
so they're comfortable there
but the white people have gone
well like
that central florida has a big
vietnamese yeah population as well
actually there's in orlando there's a
there's a small little area it's called
little vietnam yeah where it's just kind
of like this big stretch it's just like
all vietnamese restaurants
but uh the white people of [ __ ] x
generation left
all right we're ex-gen
x-gen x-gen basically left louisiana uh
mississippi
now the boomers are still there there's
a lot of them
but ex-gen's gone
now the millennials
in mississippi are like i said they're
vietnamese chinese black
um
and a lot of them are thinking about
leaving there's just greener pastures
this is too rural
you know
yeah and you know
i'm not i don't know i'm not a big fan
of like living out the middle of nowhere
to be honest there's not much to do out
there anymore yeah it's a good place to
go and retire and die in peace but yeah
if you're just gonna like gonna putter
around the garden
yeah
yeah but young people don't want to be
if you actually like want to go and like
do some [ __ ] yeah if you're [ __ ]
partying you don't want to be there
not anymore back in the back in the day
it might have been more fun but because
it was fun back in the 70s when you were
a kid
[ __ ] right a lot of underage drinking
and there's a lot of misconceptions the
way the deep south was they think what
was so religious yeah but that religion
was mostly [ __ ]
[ __ ] were [ __ ]
drinking and lots of [ __ ] sex and
they were wild
well i kind of feel like nowadays it's
kind of like transferred to like myth
yeah now it's math yeah yeah everybody's
like a day no man because it's cheap
every time i was coming down to
mississippi you stayed in mississippi my
dad's house for the summer
because i was spent half the time with
california in the other part of the half
the time mississippi mississippi was
party time when i was a kid
you know wild [ __ ] 13 year old girls
and i'm [ __ ]
12. you know what i mean it just
it was wild
real wild
uh fun a lot of fun
hot though you know
i'd come back from california guys so
hot how do you take it they go take your
clothes off you know
you wearing all them clothes
[Laughter]
they all wore [ __ ] tank tops and [ __ ]
shorts
it was like a third world but it was
[ __ ] fun real fun
everybody drinking underage and riding
three wheelers we didn't have four
wheelers yet we had three wheelers had
one wheel on the front two in the back
yeah i remember what people did tip
those [ __ ] over go down to catfish
pond [ __ ] case catch catfish and cook
them take them back and cook them and
then drink vodka
you know
and you're like 11 12. like i said what
anything else to do there's nothing else
to do and there's no cops it's just kind
of like well let's just like go out in
the woods and drink i guess yeah
yeah there's no place to go really
and you might be 12 and you might be a
13 or 14 year old girl with you know let
me and she'll [ __ ] show you her
teddies or something you're like that's
like a big deal but yeah
fun ian england says yeah the deep woods
is about meth and alcohol now yeah yeah
it was kind of what we didn't have math
back then
yeah i kept well nowadays i kind of feel
like yeah all the all the small towns
like especially in the small towns and
midwest and [ __ ] like that any kind of
small town where there's nothing to do i
kind of feel like there's like a myth
out there yeah everybody's on [ __ ]
men yeah because you need like [ __ ] to
do man yeah you need [ __ ] for your young
people to do yeah outsiders would
project this weird kind of [ __ ]
puritanism on the south
and hell no
no the south was never puritanical
it was
in church they talked that talk but in
reality they did not walk that walk no
no
there's a [ __ ] black historian named
thomas soul who [ __ ] talks a lot
about the south
okay he's a good dude and he'll tell you
he'll tell you the truth about the south
the south and uh
just this isn't top of seoul in the
south
there's very little difference between
white and black people is it was the
same culture it was the same diet
it was the same practices in church the
only difference between white people and
black people and in the south was the
amount of income but other than that it
was the same culture
same although they thought themselves to
be very different
yeah they did because i remember them
yeah but when you looking back on it no
there was very little difference
well sometimes very little different
people that are really similar but have
like one noticeable difference yeah
sometimes there's a lot more uh acrimony
between people like that than people
that are like really really different
yeah you know what i mean yeah like
people that are like mostly similar
exactly the difference between a white
southerner and a white new yorker was
vast vast the difference between a white
southerner and a black southerner no
very close very similar the only the
main difference was the amount of money
that they had but other than that they
were real similar
yeah and both were poor
it was just it's just part of like yeah
we're just slightly less just slightly
less yeah
yeah it's all on a [ __ ] spectrum
isn't it it's on a spectrum yeah all
right so
i guess i'm done talking about what i
was gonna talk about all right so i
don't know if you have anything else you
would like to add about this [ __ ]
story no well i'll go down there and
i'll start making something to eat are
you hungry yeah i'm starving
i'm still do you know that i'm still on
that's my first drink still right uh i
didn't refill it it's a drink and a half
oh okay so i had a drink and a half wow
that's like but see that's good though
yeah because well the thing about bloody
marys is that they're kind of like
savory yeah so you can't really chug
them like you would like
a regular drink i guess yeah
so i drank it much slower
we got attacked by bots there for a
while yeah okay i think there was only
like three or four okay they got rid of
them i mean we've had worse attacks
right it's usually like porn bots and
i've seen it like turning up in the
comments too like usually as soon as i
post a video
i'll get like a sex bot
like hey but it's usually in spanish but
it's just like have all these hearts and
kissy lips and [ __ ] like i think i think
bundy is telling me he was on first air
cavalry
okay
that's good that's good
yeah a lot of confederate minds are set
up by the federal government in order to
honor so to get them on board the
foreign war yeah that may be true that
may be true john
the confederate monuments might have
been funded by the north to get them on
board with joining the army's because
you have to understand here if you if
you all don't live
in the united states and maybe people up
north might not understand this
the war machine of the united states was
fueled with [ __ ] southern blood
when you join the us army
you're joining the south
when you go to a [ __ ]
the south even if now even if i'm
talking about southern california it's
still the south because it's just
mexicans whites and blacks from the
southern region not the northern regions
you got some but no
it's the south okay
you go to a u.s army chow hall what do
they serve in that chat hall southern
food or aka
soul food
militaries or armies the the [ __ ]
army language
has a southern accent to it okay
the the
the us arm
the united states was built on the backs
of [ __ ] southerners
military
militarily
and even during the war between the
states
the southern the the confederacy had
better generals
the north had a lot more in terms of
[ __ ]
in industry you know what i mean
they won they had more numbers they had
better logistics
okay the south was had real talented
generals and talented soldiers
but
the south was in agregarian society it
was a lot like feudal japan
which i've gotten to this before in
in the shows
plantation owners were kind of like
dimeo
it was not centralized like the north
was
and a lot of that war had to do with
over money
uh money and power and the fact that the
south was trying to become
industrialized
and the north wasn't going to have that
because you had ruling elites and ruling
really rich families that did not want
competition that had a lot to do with it
slavery was a huge problem
even the south did not like slavery
i'll say this again and again
for any new listeners
mississippi was the blackest of [ __ ]
states
33
african-american
it had the most slaves out of any other
state
and even that state slavery was bad in
half of the half of the uh the counties
it was it was
controversial even in those days
for many different reasons it destroyed
[ __ ] economy it sucked all the money
away you could not compete with it there
was no business can could compete with
it and the romans found the same thing
when roman elites
started to deal with german slaves and
started to insource all the labor
to german slaves running on making food
on their plant on their [ __ ]
plantations that was the end of the
republic and it became an empire
slavery is a poison
it just it just destroys every country
that has it
and um you just can't compete with it
and it was not popular in the south in
the south and it was not popular in
mississippi
uh you can
you can go look at [ __ ] there's a
whole war about it in jones county
what's the name of that movie um
the free state of free state of jones
my family is from jones county
all right uh [ __ ]
laurel mississippi
and
jones did not want anything to do with
slavery
there's a good movie about it uh free
state of jones
so
a lot of the [ __ ] history of the
south is not taught properly it's not
putting proper respect perspective it
wasn't black and white it was a lot of
gray the south was in a civil war and of
its own in the civil war period
or the war between the states
but we're gonna go ahead and check out
now it's time for us to go and i'm gonna
make us something yeah i got some of
that pork you want what pork and rice
maybe or pork potatoes pork and potatoes
would be good oh i got those uh home
fries
oh pork at home fries fries that sounds
good okay we're gonna do that you got
home fries yeah yeah from yesterday yeah
and i grew them i grew those potatoes
out in the garden we'll see there you go
[ __ ] man yeah yeah all right okay so all
right so thanks everybody for dropping
by this evening yeah uh hopefully this
was a good show i think it came out
pretty good this was like an interesting
topic i thought yeah uh so yeah we will
see you guys next time on friday night
for our uh drunken side traction so that
should be fun what let me say one thing
because i got an intelligent comment
john said that seoul claims that modern
blacks inherited the white underclass
values of the south yes they did
yes they did
a lot of the a lot of the black
ghettoness
that people would say well that's black
people doing that no that's they got
that from us they got that from white
people exactly they got that from white
southerners
and it's because
african-american culture and southern
culture was the same culture it's just
that they ran north with it after the
war
and then the evolution happened in
separate areas but you thank you for
bringing that up yes
thomas soul is exactly he is exactly
right about that
and that
white southern culture did not come from
america it came from ireland
because that's the way it was like in
ireland
but okay okay that's it but thank you
for bringing that up thank you
all right
so we'll be back on friday night for the
side track show so hopefully you guys
will join us for that where we can just
like drink and talk about whatever
so have a good rest your evening you
guys have a good day tomorrow and we
will see you guys on friday night bye